Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio. Es ist der letzte Donnerstag im Juli 2014, der 31.07. um genau zu sein, es ist kurz nach 10. Und ich heiße euch herzlich willkommen zu der Sendung, wo der Chaos Computer Club und seine anvertraunten Freunde und Sympathisanten hier das Studio übernehmen und Dinge erzählen, die mit diesen komischen Stromgeräten, neuerartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgeräten, Computern und anderen digitalen Spielereihen draußen zu tun haben. Das hat ja immer auch so ein bisschen gesellschaftliche und politische Konsequenzen. Manchmal ist es auch Hands-on-Hacking, wie es so schön heißt. Da werden also Sachen zerforscht. Und heute ist es so eine Mischung aus allem, könnte man sagen. Ihr könnt heute die Sendung übrigens nicht nur sehen. Nee, falsch rum. Ach, schon verraten und gespoilert. Nicht nur hören, sondern auch sehen. Hören natürlich, das müsste ich jetzt eigentlich nicht sagen, weil ihr macht es gerade, aber trotzdem fritz.de oder im Radio und sehen auf streaming.media.ccc.de. Denn der Chaos Computer Club bringt nicht nur Leute her, sondern auch noch haufenweise Technik. Also wir haben, glaube ich, irgendwie 5000 Kilometer mehr Kabel als normalerweise. So, das Ganze geht wie gesagt auch nicht ohne Gäste. Ich heiße herzlich willkommen vom Chaos Computer Club und seinem Umfeld Ebea Hubrich. Guten Tag.
Guten Tag, guten Abend.
Rechtsanwältin, du musst schon auf den Knopf drücken, sozusagen, und das Mikrofon, das muss dann anbleiben.
Jetzt bin ich wieder drinnen.
Jetzt bist du wieder da. Einfach einmal draufdrücken und dann anlassen.
Und dann anlassen.
Genau.
Super, ich wünsche einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Die Rechtsanwältin, vor der sogar Apple Angst hat. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte, die aber heute Abend vielleicht auch erzählt werden soll. Dann haben wir so jetzt habe ich wieder nicht ordentlich in die Vorbereitung geguckt. Monique vom ja vom Freifunk. Was genau bedeutet das? Was machst du da?
Ja, also ich habe die Initiative Freifunknet mit gegründet und ich bin auch Gründungsmitglied und Vorstand im Förderverein Freien Netzwerk e.V.
Okay, wie das alles zusammenhängt und was Freifunk ist, klären wir auch gleich. Und Mirko ist zu Gast. Hallo.
Hallo.
Du bist als was hier?
Ich bin OpenWear-Teller. Das ist eine Linux-Distribution, auf der die Freifunk-Firmware basiert.
Natürlich, die Freifunk-Firmware einer Linux-Distribution, das kennen wir auch gleich noch. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen. So, die Sendung ist heute im Prinzip, könnte man sagen, dreigeteilt. Es geht erstmal um die Idee des Freifunkens. Ich verrate mal ganz grob, es geht darum, dass alle überall WLAN haben. Wir erklären also, was das ist, wie das funktioniert, was man machen muss. Dann geht es um die Technik dahinter. Das geht nicht einfach so. Also man kann nicht nur einen Hebel umlegen, sondern es ist ein bisschen mehr Aufwand nötig. Und dann geht es auch, wir sind halt in Deutschland, auch um die juristischen Konsequenzen dieses Ganzen. Es gibt ja Menschen, die glauben immer noch, das Internet wird vor allem deshalb benutzt, damit böse Menschen Dateien tauschen. Und deswegen machen sie die freie und offene Nutzung sozusagen ein bisschen schwerer. Das hat dann Konsequenzen. Da gibt es dann Rechtsanwälte, die daran Geld verdienen. Und Politik und überhaupt, und das klären wir heute auch alles. Wir fangen aber erstmal ganz einfach an. Mit dem, was ist denn eigentlich Freifunk? Und der Aufruf zum Anruf an euch, falls ihr heute was nicht versteht, könnt ihr gerne im Anruf nochmal nachfragen. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. So, jetzt habe ich genug geredet, jetzt geht es wirklich los. Monique, was ist Freifunk?
Ja, also Freifunk ist eine Initiative und steht für freie Kommunikation in digitalen Datennetzen. Freifunkerinnen bauen Gemeinschaftsnetze in Eigenregie auf. Und frei verstehen wir dabei vor allem als öffentlich und anonym zugänglich, nicht kommerziell, es ist unzensiert, es ist im Besitz einer Gemeinschaft und dezentral organisiert.
Okay, Monique, warte, lass mich die Frage nochmal anders stellen. Was ist Freifunk? Also im Sinne von, was macht ihr da, was passiert da, wozu ist das da? Also sagen, weil das klingt jetzt so wie ein Text, der ein Politiker sozusagen gut hätte lesen können. Aber was ist Freifunk?
Wir bauen freie Netze auf. Das heißt, wir benutzen WLAN-Technologie und vernetzen Menschen untereinander mittels Mesh-Technologie. Ich glaube, dazu kommen wir dann später noch im Detail. Ja, und wir machen das, weil wir halt der Meinung sind, dass es zur Demokratisierung der Kommunikationsmedien beiträgt und wollen gegen die digitale Spaltung wirken.
Das sind so große Worte. Was bedeutet das für mich zu sagen? Ich stehe jetzt hier und denke so, okay, Freifunk. Das Einzige, wo ich mit in Berührung gekommen bin, ist, ich laufe durch die Stadt und mein Handyanbieter hat mich schon wieder gedrosselt, weil die Flatrate dann nach ein paar Gigabyte doch wieder vorbei ist. Und ich bin auf der Suche nach WLANs und sehe ein Freifunk-WLAN-Ecke. Das hört sich gut an. Da gibt es bestimmt besonders kostenloses Netz. Was ist das? Was passiert da?
Ja, also das ist ein Teil, den wir machen. Genau. Also es gibt im öffentlichen Raum frei öffentlich zugängliche Freifunk Cotspots. Und die werden von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern oder Menschen, Menschen geteilt. Also sprich die teilen ihre privaten Internetanschlüsse über unsere Mesh-Netzwerke. Das ist aber nur ein kleiner Teil dessen, was so ein Freifunknetz ausmacht. Ein Freifunknetz ist halt auch eine unabhängige, vom Internet unabhängige Infrastruktur, in der Menschen Daten tauschen können, Dienste anbieten und eben auch ihre Internetzugänge anderen zur Verfügung stellen können.
Und warum macht man das?
Weil das Internet, wie es ja sicherlich jeder mitbekommen hat, nicht so ganz unseren Idealvorstellungen entspricht. Das wird zum Beispiel eben teilweise zensiert. Es wird mitgetrackt, was die Nutzer da drin so machen in diesem Netz, in diesem Internet. Es ist kommerziell und insofern kann sich auch nicht jeder leisten, da mitzuspielen. Wir stellen uns das anders vor. Vor allen Dingen ist das Internet aber auch recht zentral organisiert. Du bist halt abhängig von deinem Provider. Die Provider sind sozusagen die Mautstellen des Internet. Wir denken halt, das müsste eigentlich alles frei sein. Die Infrastruktur sollte jedem zugänglich sein.
Aber das hört sich so an wie eine Vereinigung, eingeschworene, technisch sehr versierte Idealisten, die ein extra Netz aufbauen, wo sie dann unter ihresgleichen Dinge austauschen können. Ist es jetzt schon so gedacht, dass wir alle davon partizipieren oder ist es wirklich als eine Art Eliten-Internet gedacht?
Nee, ganz und gar nicht. Freifunk hat sich das total auf die Fahne geschrieben, das eben aus der Techie-Ecke rauszuholen. Ja, so hat es ganz bestimmt angefangen, sehr, sehr technisch. Und wir versuchen eben, das deutlich zu machen, wie das Internet momentan funktioniert, wie es vielleicht anders oder besser funktionieren könnte. Das zeigen wir in unseren Freifunknetzen. Auch so Stichwort Netzneutralität etc. Und wollen da halt eigentlich auch ganz viel Aufklärungsarbeit leisten. Aber das gelingt manchmal auch nur zum Teil, denn es ist eben schon technisch und man muss sich schon so ein bisschen einfummeln, um jetzt so die Technik in der letzten Gänze, sag ich mal, so dieses ganze Routing-Protokolle, Meshen, all diese ganzen Dinge, das dauert schon. Aber erst mal kann man auch sehr einfach mitmachen. Man kann sich einen vorgeflächten Router in vielen Communities auch abholen, also einen vorgeflächten WLAN-Router. Der hat schon sozusagen neu bespielt mit einer neuen Firmware, neuer Software.
Also wir halten fest, ich hole mir einen Router ab, da sind Dinge drauf, die machen, dass Freifunk funktioniert.
Genau, und den Stab sitzt du einfach zu Hause an deinem Provider gestellten Router einfach noch mit dran. Dann macht er ein eigenes Netz auf und dann kaufst du das Freifunknetz. Der kann aber auch mehrere Netze aufmachen, also auch noch dein privates Zuhause-Netz. Und mit diesem Freifunknetz teilst du deinen Internetanschluss mit den anderen.
Okay, also die einfachste Art, um aktiv beim Freifunk mitzumachen, wäre, sich so ein Ding abzuholen, irgendwo hinzustellen und zu sagen, so hier, da können jetzt auch andere Leute mein Internet benutzen. Das habe ich schon erzählt, meine Begegnung mit Freifunk ist vor allen Dingen die, ich gehe irgendwo hin und gucke nach einem WLAN, da steht dann Freifunk dran und dann logge ich mich da ein und dann funktioniert das nicht.
Oh nein, wieso nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, man loggt sich dann in das WLAN ein und dann sagt auch das Neuartige Grunfunkumfangsgerät, ja ich habe hier eine Netzwerkverbindung und dann gibt man halt keine Ahnung, fritzt eh ein und dann passiert nichts.
Okay, also mal zu den Hintergründen. Es gibt diese Freifunk-Firmware für WLAN-Router.
Was ist eine Firmware?
Eine Firmware ist eine Software für so Kleinstcomputer, wie zum Beispiel Router, die haben halt keine Gigabyte-Festplatten, sondern so was wie vier oder acht Megabyte Flash-Speicher. Da Bedarf ist dann einer speziellen Firmware.
Also Firmware ist die Software, die macht, dass der Router mir das Internet zur Verfügung stellt und das auch an meine Geräte zu Hause verteilt und so was? Genau.
Und der größte Teil der Router-Firmwares basiert auf Linux. Und die Freifunk-Firmware basiert auf OpenWrt und OpenWrt ist eine Linux-basierende Embedded-Distribution.
Das ist wahrscheinlich egal, ob man das weiß oder nicht. Oder ist Embedded-Distribution wieder irgendwas, was man auch noch lernen muss?
Nö, das heißt nur, dass es keine Linux-Distribution für Desktop-Computer, Notebooks oder Server ist, sondern halt für Kleinstcomputer.
Okay, also jemand hat sich hingesetzt und hat sich die Mühe gemacht, eine extra Software für Router, also die nur auf Routern funktioniert, zu schreiben?
Genau. Oder halt auf Kleinstcomputern und auf anderen auch. Aber ja, das ist OpenWRT, wo wir übrigens gerade das zweite Release-Candidate von einem neuen Release veröffentlicht haben. Und dieses läuft auf einer Großzahl von Routern. Man kann da in einer Tabelle nachgucken, welche Router unterstützt werden von OpenWRT. Und auf diese kann man dann in aller Regel auch die Freifunk-Firmware flashen. Ja, dann funktioniert dieser eine Knoten nicht. Das Tolle an dem Freifunk-Netzwerk ist die Vermaschung. Das ist eine zentrale Idee von Freifunk. Das bedeutet, okay, ein bisschen Details. WLAN-Geräte können in drei Modi geschaltet werden. Zum Beispiel den AccessPoint, wie es der heimische WLAN-Router ist, oder den Client-Mode, wie es dann Notebooks sind oder Smartphones, die sich am AccessPoint anmelden. Aber es gibt noch einen dritten Modus.
Ich möchte es wirklich so halten, dass wirklich alle Leute mitkommen, die gerade eingeschaltet haben. Also es gibt drei Modi. Einer ist dieses, das Gerät greift das Internet, das aus der Dose fällt und verteilt es an mehrere Geräte.
Genau.
Das ist der erste.
Das ist der AccessPoint.
Client ist sozusagen alles, was wir benutzen eigentlich. Also Computer, Smartphone, WLAN-Radio, die können genau eine Sache, nämlich sich in ein bestehendes WLAN einloggen.
Richtig.
Und sozusagen dort das Netz abholen.
Und der AccessPoint verwaltet diese Geräte.
Okay.
Und dann gibt es den dritten Modus, das ist der Ad hoc-Modus. Und dort sind alle Geräte, alle WLAN-Geräte gleichberechtigt. Und damit kann man eine Vermaschung aufbauen. Also nehmen wir als Beispiel, es gibt drei WLAN-Geräte, A, B, C, D. Und wenn die alle im Ad hoc-Modus sind, dann kann A, B sehen, B, C, C, D. Aber zum Beispiel A kann nicht direkt D sehen. Und dann gibt es spezielle Software, im Freifunk im Normalfall OLSR oder Batman. Das sind einfach zwei Namen für Software, sodass A über B über C D sehen kann. Und wenn jetzt Router D Internetzugang hat, A aber nicht, kann A über B über C über D ins Internet kommen.
Wer jetzt noch mitgekommen ist, hebt bitte die Hand oder ruft an, 0331 77 97 110. Es ist so eine Art stille Post unter Netzwerkgeräten, könnte man sich vorstellen. Also in jedem Zimmer sitzt einer und ich komme vom Bad ins Wohnzimmer und das Schlafzimmer rufen, aber nicht in die Küche.
So ist es.
Aber der im Wohnzimmer kann in die Küche rufen.
Genau.
So, das heißt und wenn sich diese vier Geräte irgendwie untereinander sozusagen sehen können, dann werfe ich an einer beliebigen Stelle Internet rein und dann kriegen die das alle oder wie?
Genau und in der Realität sieht das so aus, dass wir sogenannte Mesh-Wolken von über 100 Knoten haben, wo dann ein Großteil der Knoten auch Internetzugang hat und diese Internetzugänge der gesamten Mesh-Wolke zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Und diese Protokolle machen dann, dass ich als jemand, der im Freifunknetzwerk ist, aber gerade kein Internet zur Verfügung hat, also kein direktes, über den kürzesten Weg Internet bekomme oder einen anderen Knoten erreiche.
Okay, also im Prinzip eine große Anzahl von Geräten, die untereinander kommunizieren und so irgendwie Netzwerk miteinander herstellen. Warum ist das von Vorteil? Also ich meine, ich hab doch Internet zu Hause.
Ja, die Idee von Freifunk ist ja auch ein dezentrales Netzwerk, wie Monique schon sagte, parallel zum Internet aufzubauen, sodass uns da niemand einreden kann oder reinreden kann. Niemand kann das einfach abschalten. Knoten können kommen und gehen, diese Wolken können damit wachsen oder schrumpfen, aber es gibt keine zentrale Stelle, die da irgendwie abgeschaltet oder manipuliert werden kann.
Okay, also wir haben halt dieses Netzwerk, was in sich erstmal gut funktioniert, aber trotzdem muss ich ja noch in das Internet hinein. Wie ich Freifunk bis jetzt immer so verstanden habe, ist es so, dass einzelne Teilnehmer in diesem Netzwerk haben dann halt einfach einen eigenen Internetanschluss und sagen dann so, hier, könnt ihr mitbenutzen. Aber dann bin ich ja sozusagen trotzdem von den großen Internetanbietern abhängig, nur es verteilt sich halt ein bisschen. Oder gibt es da noch sozusagen extra eigene Freifunk-Eintrittspunkte ins Internet?
Na ja, also die gibt es. Also wir haben ganz kürzlich sind wir vom BKIX eingeladen worden und sind da sozusagen direkt eigen im Internet verbunden, ohne jetzt ein Provider noch dazwischen. Wir haben auch schon lange das deutsche Forschungsnetz, wobei das ist jetzt nicht besonders viel Bandbreite, wo wir auch ein Teil Bandbreite mit nutzen.
Aber ist halt auch keine Firma.
Genau und generell ist die Idee aber schon, ja genau, man erinnert sich vielleicht, es kann ja andere politische Zeiten geben, wo bestimmte Dienste oder gar das ganze Netz blockiert wird, beispielsweise, weil der Staat kein Interesse daran hat, kritische Meinungen im Internet verbreitet zu sehen. Oder es könnte auch Katastrophen geben, die die zentralen Zugangspunkte, wie zum Beispiel in der dritten Welt, im Bangladesch, den wird die Infrastruktur regelmäßig weggespült. Also die Infrastruktur, die klassische Internet, sozusagen, dann plötzlich nicht mehr da ist. Und dann ist halt so ein dezentrales Netz von großem Vorteil, weil da können zwar einzelne Knoten mal ausfallen, aber deswegen hat man trotzdem noch das Netz. Und weil es sich auch verhältnismäßig einfach und eben drahtlos aufbauen lässt, ist es auch ganz schnell wieder da. Selbst wenn es mal kurz weg ist, lässt es sich auch sehr schnell wieder aufbauen. Wir haben auch viele Projekte in dritten Weltländern oder hatten auch schon Kontakt mit so, wie sagt man, Katastrophenschutzbehörden, auch in verschiedenen Ländern und so, die daran sehr interessiert sind. Das macht schon einen Sinn, diese unabhängige Infrastruktur.
Wird das da verwendet? Gibt es da Beispiele?
Es gibt jetzt im Katastrophenschutz.
Naja, oder halt in der dritten Welt oder wo auch immer.
Ja, absolut. Da gibt es einige Beispiele. Es gibt Communitys, wireless Network-Communities auf der ganzen Welt. Obwohl, ich muss eine Einschränkung machen. Aus Russland und China habe ich keine Information. Aber ansonsten gibt es die tatsächlich auf der ganzen Welt. Es gab auch Projekte in Afrika, wo nicht nur Open Source Software, wie unsere Firmware zum Einsatz kamen, sondern sogar Open Source Hardware gebaut wurde. Sprich ein eigenes Handy eigentlich, was über diese unabhängige Infrastruktur telefoniert oder daran sozusagen beteiligt. Man kann diese Infrastruktur auch zum kostenlosen Telefonieren, Broadcasting, also sprich Radio kann man darüber streamen innerhalb dieses Netzes und so weiter. Du kannst also alles anbieten, was du im Internet auch anbieten kannst.
Also das heißt sozusagen, ich kann schon sozusagen, selbst wenn es keinen Zugang ins Internet außen gibt, ist es sozusagen innerhalb dieses Freifunk-Dings, dieses Freifunk-Dingens kann man untereinander kommunizieren.
Ja, man kann Daten austauschen, man kann breitbandig, man kann spielen, man kann Leute eben nutzen, das ist tatsächlich auch dafür, dass sie da Gameserver reinhängen. Man kann Daten tauschen und so weiter und so fort. Also wie gesagt, wir hatten auch schon Radiostreams.
Das klingt für mich jetzt aber immer noch so, als ob das wirklich eine gute Alternative wäre, wenn das Internet mal weg ist. Oder sozusagen für den Fall, dass wir das hier irgendwann auch mal brauchen. Aber als ob es mir jetzt als Person als User nichts wirklich einfacher macht.
Also es ist immer eine schwierige Diskussion zu sagen, was kann Freifunk besser als das Internet?
Soviel habe ich schon verstanden, nicht als das Internet. Aber was habe ich für einen Vorteil, wenn ich jetzt nicht meine zugegebenerweise privilegierte Position, aber mein 50er VDSL zu Hause habe, was ist besser, wenn ich Freifunk nutze?
Also WLAN-Technologie hat sich in den letzten Jahren enorm weiterentwickelt. Wir können mittlerweile mehrere Gigabits über den Ether schicken. Und das ist deutlich mehr, als der normale Internetkunde an Internetbandbreite zur Verfügung gestellt bekommt. Das heißt, innerhalb des Freifunknetzwerkes hat man deutlich höhere Bandbreiten und kann deutlich mehr Daten tauschen und komplett unzensiert, ohne dass da jemand zwischensitzt, das Ganze halt machen. Es ist halt das eigene Netzwerk und nicht von irgendeinem Provider dazwischen.
Es gibt noch einen weiteren Vorteil. Wir tunneln den Internettraffic ja ins Ausland teilweise. Also sprich, wir sammeln den Traffic, den die Nutzer machen an Gateways, die via VPNs ins Ausland rausfallen oder zu unseren eigenen Providern. Also der Förderverein Freien Netzwerke ist ein Provider. Und somit ist der Nutzer nicht direkt zurückverfolgbar, sondern immer nur bis zu dem Provider. Das heißt, du bist anonym unterwegs. Das sehe ich als einen großen Vorteil an. Und wenn wir das zum Beispiel in den Niederlanden rausfallen lassen, dann kannst du zum Beispiel auch YouTube-Filme schauen, die eben in Deutschland leider zensiert sind. Aber da du ja in den Niederlanden surfst, was auch völlig legal ist, nebenbei bemerkt, jeder kann sich einen VPN im Ausland kaufen oder in Schweden. Dann kannst du halt auch ganz andere Inhalte sehen, die dir sonst hier in einem neuen Internet verwehrt bleiben.
In dem Zusammenhang kann man vielleicht auch noch mal das Projekt der Freifunk Freedom Fighter Box erwähnen. Wir hatten mal ziemlich viele Router gestellt bekommen und auch VPN-Zugänge und viele Bars und Vereine.
Jetzt musst du noch mal kurz VPN erklären.
VPN ist ein Tunneling-Protokoll. Das bedeutet, dass ich eine Verbindung zu jemandem aufmache und darüber meinen eigentlichen Internetverkehr dann abwicke. Das ist, als wenn ich jetzt eine Postkarte habe, die würde ich an dich schicken wollen und der Postbote könnte sie lesen. Aber jetzt packe ich diese Postkarte noch mal in einen Briefumschlag mit der Adresse des VPN-Anbieters rauf und verschlüssel das Ganze. Und jetzt kann der Postbote aufgrund der Verschlüsselung das Ganze nicht aufmachen und nicht lesen. Und das Ganze landet dann bei dem VPN-Provider. Der kann das dann entschlüsseln, aufmachen und dem eigentlichen Empfänger zukommen lassen.
Also der wirft es dann irgendwie normal in die Post, aber bis dahin kann man es sozusagen nicht lesen. Also praktisch bedeutet das, wenn ich ins Internet gehe, da kann er immer meinen Internetprovider sehen, was ich mache. Und das geht nicht mehr, wenn ich über einen VPN gehe, sondern dann vertraue ich quasi dem VPN-Anbieter.
Genau.
Und wenn der im Ausland sitzt, hat das Konsequenzen, weil die irgendwie nicht so viel Daten speichern wollen, können, müssen oder wie?
Genau, bei der Freifunk FreedomFighterBox zum Beispiel hatten wir VPN-Zugänge von einem Provider aus Schweden. Und in Schweden muss man nicht protokollieren. Das heißt, der Provider kann einfach jederzeit sagen, ich weiß nicht, wem, also ich hab die Zuordnung zwischen Kunde und IP-Adresse nicht. Und somit kann halt keine Zuordnung passieren.
Das Gleiche ist auch bei uns der Fall generell. Also bei allen Communities, wir zeichnen keine Daten auf.
Okay, also gerade im Snowden-Zeitalter, um das große Wort mal zu benutzen, hört sich das erstmal nicht nach einer schlechten Idee an. Mirko, ich habe aber noch diese eine Frage. Nämlich die Frage, warum das oft nicht funktioniert, wenn ich mich in dieses Freifunk-WLAN einlogge, dass ich irgendwo unterwegs finde.
Ja, wir erinnern uns an diese drei WLAN-Modi. Und dieser Ad-hoc-Modus ist der, der am seltensten verwendet wird. Und leider legen die Hersteller von WLAN-Geräten auch weniger Wert auf die Qualität dieses Modus. So, dass nicht alle Geräte den Ad-hoc-Modus beherrschen.
Also die sagen, wenn ich so ein Freifunknetz sehe, dann ist es immer so ein Ad-hoc-Modus-Ding, sie?
Nein, nicht zwangsläufig. Also aktuelle WLAN-Hardware kann man auch sagen, dass sie sowohl den Ad-hoc-Modus als auch zum Beispiel den Access-Point-Modus machen soll, sodass dieses WLAN-Gerät, also im Normalfall der WLAN-Router, dann sowohl im Freifunknetzwerk ist, als auch als ganz normaler Access-Point dann das Freifunknetzwerk anderen Geräten zur Verfügung stellt, die sich dann als Client im Station-Mode mit dem Access-Point verbinden.
Also quasi der Access-Point, der WLAN-Router übernimmt dann die Aufgabe, sich per Ad-hoc-Modus mit den anderen zu vernetzen vom Freifunknetzwerk. Und es trotzdem noch als normales Internet rauszuwerfen, für Geräte wie mein Smartphone, das nichts anderes kann.
Genau so ist es.
Das hört sich ganz großartig an. Ich möchte sowas bitte auch. Das noch, ne, wir machen jetzt erst mal Nachrichten. Danach klären wir, wie dich diese Dinge aneinanderstehen müssen. So, dann erst mal bis hierhin und dann bis gleich.
Und dazu ein fettes Fritz-Konzert mit einer großartigen Live-Band Alpenheer. Fritz präsentiert Imagine Dragons Mittwoch, 20.
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation will mehr tun, um Ebola in den Griff zu kriegen in Westafrika. Die WHO teilte am Abend mit, dass sie ein Notfallprogramm in Höhe von 100 Millionen Dollar auflegt. Morgen soll es dazu einen Krisengipfel der betroffenen Länder in Guinea geben. Guinea ist selbst von der Ebola-Epidemie betroffen, genauso wie Sierra Leone und Liberia. Bisher wurden laut WHO mehr als 1.300 Menschen angesteckt, über die Hälfte von ihnen starben. Der Berliner Bezirk Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg muss den Polizeieinsatz an der besetzten Gerhard-Hauptmann-Schule nicht bezahlen. In Senator Henkel sagte in der RBB-Abendschau, dass es nach rechtlicher Prüfung keine Möglichkeit gibt, den Bezirk in Regress zu nehmen. Deshalb müsse die Polizei die Kosten tragen. Henkel selbst findet das falsch. Er warf Bezirksbürgermeisterin Hermann vor, den Einsatz durch ihre Entscheidungsfeigheit in die Länge gezogen zu haben. Dadurch, dass er eine Woche gedauert hat, liegen alleine die Personalkosten bei 5 Millionen Euro. Berlins Justizsenator Heilmann ist erleichtert, dass jetzt auch der zweite entflohene Häftling aus der JVA Morbid wieder gefasst ist. Dem RBB sagte er, dass er der Polizei und den Strafverfolgungsbehörden sehr dankbar ist. Das SEK stellte den zweiten Gefängnisausbrecher am Nachmittag in einer Wohnung in Reinickendorf. Seinen Komplizen hatte die Polizei schon Anfang Juni in einem Berliner Hotel festgenommen. Beide Männer waren im Mai aus dem Gefängnis in Morbid abgehauen, sie zersägten die Gitterstäbe ihrer Zellen, seilten sich ab und bezwangen eine Mauer und Stacheldraht. Ist mein Sport nicht da? Warte mal.
Der Sport ist weg. Wir suchen nach dem Sport. Ist er da? Achtung!
Aha, ist nämlich wichtig. Die deutschen U19-Fußballer sind Europameister geworden. Die DFB-Auswahl besiegte am Abend im Finale in Budapest, Portugal, mit 1 zu 0. Damit holten die deutschen Junioren nach 1981 und 2008 zum dritten Mal den Titel und den Siegtreffer. Jetzt kommt's. Erzielte Mukta von Hertha BSC in der 39. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Pankow 17°C, Tempelhof noch 20°C, Cottbus und Netzeband auch 17°C, Potsdam 18°C und manch nur 21°C. In der Nacht bleibt es trocken, bei 16 bis 13°C minimal. Morgen wird es dann wärmer, als es heute war. Wir kriegen 28°C maximal, wieder viel Sonne und wie es aussieht auch keinen Regen. Stadtverkehr Berlin, 111 Stadt, Autobahnstadt, einwärts. Die Einfahrt Antonienstraße ist gesperrt, die wird nämlich geputzt. Friedrichshain, Karl-Marx-Allee, zwischen Warschauer und Lichtenberger Straße wegen der Biermeile bis Montag. Einschränkungen Richtung Alexanderplatz. Brandenburg B5, Berlin Richtung Nauen. Zwischen Elztal und der A10 auf Fahrt Spandau, der Stock der Verkehr. Zur S-Bahn zwischen Friedrichstraße und Zoologisch im Garten fahren nur noch bis Montag früh Busse. Alternativ könnte die Regionalbahn nutzen. Ab Montag ist dann der Bereich zwischen Ostbahnhof und Friedrichstraße gesperrt, doch immer seid gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Klickt einfach fritz.de slash TV.
Und jetzt präsentiert das Chaos Radio die Nerd-News, verfasst vom Chaos Computer Club, vorgetragen von Scarlett Kuboszek.
Werbe-Drossel für Kabel-Deutschland. Wer Internet-Drosselung anbietet, muss auch Internet-Drosselung draufschreiben. Die Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband war vor Gericht gegen Kabel-Deutschland vorgegangen. Der Kabel-Anbieter behält sich nämlich vor, die Geschwindigkeit drastisch zu reduzieren, wenn gewisse Filesharing-Dienste mehr als 10 GB pro Tag verursachen. Das hat die Firma aber gut im Kleingedruckten versteckt, statt offensichtlich darauf hinzuweisen und darf genau das in Zukunft nicht mehr. Freuen wir uns also in Zukunft auf neue Werbeversprechen, wie tolles neues Internet, fast ungebremst meistens jedenfalls. Kanzlerin-Handyhersteller verkauft Der kanadische Handyhersteller Blackberry hat die deutsche Firma SecuSmart übernommen. SecuSmart ist auf sichere Kommunikation spezialisiert und stellt unter anderem die im Kanzlerinhandyskandal bekannt gewordene Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung für die Bundesregierung her. Blackberry wiederum ist vor allem im Business-Bereich aktiv und hat erst Anfang des Jahres einen umfangreichen Auftrag des Pentagon erhalten. Vielleicht wird ja das Kanzlerin-Handy dann direkt von der NSA ausgeliefert. Schlüsselnachmacher per Smartphone Alles, was ihr zum Einbrechen in die Wohnung braucht, ist ein Smartphone und ganz kurz den passenden Schlüssel. So ist Wired-Redakteur Andy Greenberg in die Wohnung eines Bekannten eingebrochen, dank des Dienstes KiMi. Ist das nämlich überhaupt kein Problem. KiMi erlaubt es, mit der passenden Smartphone-App seinen Schlüssel zu fotografieren, um im Verlustfall einfach wieder beschaffen zu können. Greenberg hat nun statt seines Schlüsseles einfach den seines Nachbarn fotografiert und in einem KiMi-Automaten in seiner Nähe kopieren lassen. Einfacher haben es Einbrecher nur noch, wenn ihr die Wohnungstür einfach gleich ganz offen stehen lasst.
Scarlett Kubosak mit den Nerdnews vom Chaosradio.
Danke.
Heute am 31. Juli 2014 um kurz nach halb elf das Chaosradio 203 mit dem Thema Störerhaftung und Freifunk. Mit dem Freifunk haben wir uns schon ein bisschen beschäftigt. Wir haben gelernt, da geht es darum, dass man einfach kleine Geräte, so umgebaute WLAN-Router zu Hause hinstellt. Die unterhalten sich dann untereinander und machen sozusagen noch mal ein extra Internet auf. Das hat ein paar Vorteile, nämlich a kann man, wenn das eigene Internet aufs Feld vom Internet anderer profitieren und man kann untereinander Daten tauschen und man kann sogar quasi nicht über deutsches Internet, sondern auch über eins surfen, das woanders rausfällt, was dann möglicherweise bei YouTube unter Umständen ein paar Vorteile hat. Was mich jetzt noch interessiert hat, ist Beya, Monique und Mirko. Herzlich willkommen noch mal zurück. Ihr habt ja gesagt, dass das Ganze funktioniert, indem diese Geräte miteinander kommunizieren. Jetzt ist es ja so, ihr habt auch gesagt, das sind umgebaute WLAN-Router, also quasi die Hardware, die man ganz normal im Elektromarkt kaufen kann, nur mit einer anderen Software draufgespielt. Jetzt ist es so, wenn ich bei mir in der Wohnung von einem Einwohnzimmer in die Küche gehe, dann ist die Wand dazwischen schon so dick, dass das ein bisschen schwierig ist mit der Verbindung. Jetzt hab ich dir gesagt, das Ziel ist es, ein richtig großes Netzwerk hinzukriegen. Also quasi länderübergreifend. Ich stell mir das schon in die Nachbarwohnung komisch. Kompliziert vor, wie weit ist denn da die Reichweite? Also wie dicht stehen denn diese Dinger, müssen diese Dinger zusammenstehen?
Oh, das kommt ganz drauf an. So aktuelle WLAN-Router.
Ich wüsste eine Antwort. Deswegen wollte ich mal, worauf kommst du denn an?
Oh nein, auf die WLAN-Hardware. Also in erster Linie natürlich alt-neu in der vergangenen Zeit ist einiges passiert. Reichweiten wurden vergrößert. So was wie Packet-Loss bedeutet, dass bestimmte Pakete auf der Strecke bleiben, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Dafür wurden Algorithmen entwickelt, um das Ganze zu vermindern. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch so was wie Richtfunk im WLAN-Bereich. Das bedeutet, dass man damit wirklich Kilometer überbrücken kann.
Also kann, aber wie ist es denn jetzt zu sagen? Das Standard Szenario ist ja, ich kaufe mir so einen 0815-Router, mach da eine andere Software drauf, stell die bei mir hin.
Ja, also es gibt schon diverse Strecken und diverse Access Points, an die man sich klinken kann. Man kann zum Beispiel, also ja, im Optimalfall kauft man sich halt so einen Router und kann die sich direkt in das Freifunknetz einklinken, insofern irgendwie Nachbarn oder Nachbarsnachbarn auch schon irgendwie in dieser Wolke mit drin sind.
Also im selben Haut, der Nachbarshaus ist durchaus realistisch.
Das ist auf jeden Fall realistisch, ja. Und dann gibt es halt die Richtfunkstrecken und man kann sich auch in diese mit einklinken. Mit WLAN-Routern, die halt irgendwie Richtfunk können, kann man dann auch wirklich deutlich größere Distanzen überbrücken und sich in andere Wolken mit einklinken.
Ich wollte kurz nachfragen, wegen des Richtfunks. Das ist aber schon teurer vermutlich, also ein bisschen höherer, schnellerer Aufwand, dass sie das können. Dann muss man auch wissen, wo man die Antenne hinzielt. Also Richtfunk hört sich ein bisschen danach an, dass man dann so 36 Grad Nordost.
Ja, ganz so schlimm ist es nicht, aber man muss schon richten. Das ist richtig. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel die openwifimap.net. Das ist eine Karte, die verzeichnet alle Freifunkrouten, gerade nur in Berlin. Ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher.
Es sind noch ein paar mehr Communities drauf. Man kann eigentlich unter freifunk.net sieht man eine Karte von den lokalen Communities. Wenn man auf die Webseiten geht, dann siehst du jeweils das lokale Netz.
Da kann man also gucken, wo man ist und dann die richtige Karte rauswohnen.
Also man muss nicht auf gut Glück irgendwie durch die Wohnung rennen, sondern kann sich schon auf dieser Karte.
Aber in Berlin, das wollte Mirko vielleicht gerade erzählen, gibt es tatsächlich schon ein großes sogenanntes Backbone-Netz. Also das sind diese Richtfunkstrecken, die auf Häuserdächern, Kirchdächern, Rathausdächern installiert sind. Und das ist tatsächlich schon zu einem Ring in der Innenstadt geschlossen. Das heißt, da gibt es echt gute Chancen, dass da schon was in der Nähe ist. Und das wird demnächst auch noch weiter ausgebaut.
Okay, es gibt das anscheinend in Berlin. Gibt es da so Stadtteile, so hipster Stadtteile, also Freifunk-hipster Stadtteile? Alles ganz Friedrichshain hat Freifunk, nur das Lichtenberg ist noch oder irgendwie so?
Ich könnte ja mal bashen, wo kein Freifunk ist. Erstaunlicherweise gibt es in Mitte sehr wenig Freifunk.
Also wir kooperieren mittlerweile auch mit Bezirken, zum Beispiel Kreuzberg-Friedrichshain, wo wir jetzt ohne viel Bürokratie auf Rathausdächer zum Beispiel dürfen, um dort WLAN-Hardware zu verbauen und das Freifunk-Netzwerk auszubauen.
Die Hipster, Freifunk-Hipster-Bezirke sind Neukölln, Kreuzberg, Friedrichshain, da ist ziemlich viel Freifunk.
Wobei Charlottenburg doch auch gut dabei ist mittlerweile, oder?
Hey, selbst Köpenick ist am Start.
So, das heißt, Berlin ist gut versorgt, aber da kann man jetzt wirklich sagen, also ist ja nicht so, dass es in Berlin kein Internet gibt. Also ja, es gibt immer noch so ein bisschen Glasfaserwüste, wo man nur ganz schmales DSL hat und so was. Aber generell in Berlin Netz zu haben, ist schon jetzt nicht so das große Problem. Also einzelne Leute mögen da widersprechen, aber so statistisch gesehen. Eigentlich wäre es auch eine super gute Idee, so was auf dem Land zu machen. Also, weil ich kenne sehr viele Brandenburger, die auch hier, also letzte Woche zum Beispiel im Telekommunikations-Horror-Bloom anrufen, sagen so, ja, aber uns gibt es doch gar kein Internet. Wäre denn das, ginge das auch sozusagen, dass man das hier über weite Strecken macht?
Ja, das gibt es auch. Es gibt in Brandenburg, also es gibt in Potsdam, gibt es auch eine Freifunk-Community. Es gibt aber auch Communities in ländlichen Regionen, wo sich kleine Dörfer, was natürlich relativ schnell geht, so ein Dorf abzudecken, oder wo sich in einem Dorf gibt es Internet, in dem nächsten Dorf nicht, und da hat man dann halt eine Richtfunksstrecke über Land gemacht, um das Internet dahin zu bringen. Zum Beispiel Sundhausen und Umgebung, das ist ein schönes Beispiel. Oder es gibt auch in Leipzig und Umgebung Beispiele, es gibt in Franken Beispiele, also auf jeden Fall gibt es auch Freifunk auf dem Lande.
Gibt es denn eigentlich Leute, die sich darum kümmern, wo man sagen kann, wir haben kein Internet, das Nachbardorf hat auch kein Internet, aber wir würden gerne so ein Freifunk-Dingsy machen?
Also, um Freifunk-Dingsy zu machen, brauchst du erstmal kein Internet. Dann hast du schon mal ein lokales Netz zwischen den ganzen Dörfern, wo die ihre lokalen Ideen, Nachrichten und so weiter austauschen können. Das gab es zum Beispiel in Dänemark, in Diosland, da waren 80.000 Einwohner in einer ländlichen Region abgeschnitten von den bösen Providern, für die sich das nicht gelohnt hat, dort Internet hinzubringen und die haben sich gesagt, was solls, wir kaufen uns das letzte Stück Internet, wo das endet, kurz vor Diosland, den Zugang und vernetzen von da aus unsere ganze Region selbst über Land mit Richtfunk.
Okay, aber das braucht man dann irgendwo.
Wenn du Internetzugang haben möchtest, brauchst du irgendwo Internetzugang.
Aber die Idee wäre, möglicherweise gibt es ja die Freifunker, ja so ausgebufft oder am Start, dass man sagen kann, na gut, wenn ihr wirklich gar nichts habt, dann legen wir euch was dahin und dann macht ihr den Rest mit Freifunk.
Na ja, also Infrastruktur, das kostet ja halt schon tatsächlich trotzdem auch Geld, also die Hardware oder sowas.
Ja, aber ihr habt ja vorhin erzählt, dass irgendwie beim deutschen Forschungsnetzwerk und eigenes Backbone Zeug und ich dachte ja nur, da bin ich nur gefragt. Was mich auch noch frage ist, wie kommt man am Anfang auf eine Idee? Also ich kann mir so sagen vorstellen, klar, irgendwie es gibt eine Technologie und dann sozusagen Leute, die gerne basteln, sagen dann, geil, wir probieren das mal aus. Aber ich vermute jetzt, Freifunk hört sich an, dass es schon so groß ist, dass es mehr sind als nur die Leute, die wirklich selber einen Lötkolben in die Hand nehmen. Gibt es irgendwie eine Geschichte hinter diesem ganzen Verein?
Ja, also genau, Freifunk ist auf keinen Fall jetzt nur Techies, muss man sozusagen, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, meine Mitgründer und ich, wir sind alle keine Hacker, sondern haben schon auch mit der IT-Branche zu tun gehabt und hatten sozusagen tatsächlich 2001 das ganze so an hier in Berlin, hatten wir tatsächlich das Problem, dass in Ostberlin oder auch aber in Ostdeutschland einfach kein breitbandiges Internet gab. Die Leitensgeschichte mit dem Glasfaserkabel der Telekom kennen sicherlich viele, sodass man sich überlegt hat, Mensch, auf der einen Straßenseite gibt es irgendwie Internet, auf der anderen nicht und dann fing man halt an, so mit WLAN rumzubasteln und halt eben alles sehr technisch. Naja, und dann haben wir uns überlegt, das muss doch irgendwie noch weitergehen können, davon sollten doch noch mehr Leute profitieren können und haben dann halt Freifunk net erfunden, im Prinzip als Kommunikationsplattform. Einmal für die Leute, die schon aktiv sind, also sprich die Aktivisten aus den unterschiedlichsten Ecken, da zusammenzubringen, damit nicht jeder das Rad neuer finden muss. Und andererseits eben diese Aufklärungsarbeit zu betreiben. Also wir haben dann halt Infoveranstaltungen gemacht in den Kiezen. Es gab auf der Seabase damals, was ja ein Hacker-Space ist, hier in der Rungerstraße mittlerweile, gab es das Wafelöten. Da wurden tatsächlich damals noch Antennen gebaut. Das machen wir heute nicht mehr, weil die Hardware doch günstig, kostengünstig geworden ist. Ja, und so fing das Ganze an. Und dann gab es auch, war eben uns auch immer diese soziale Vernetzung sehr wichtig. Und dann haben wir so ein erstes Event in der Seabase gemacht, die Freifunk Summer Convention, aus der sich dann das jährliche Wireless Community Weekend entwickelt hat. Und da haben wir dann halt auch die ersten internationalen Kontakte geknüpft. Ich könnte das noch ewig weiter erzählen, da gab es noch ganz viele spannende internationale Events, die da folgten.
Aber wir haben sozusagen, wann ist es denn umgekippt? Also sozusagen so von, das ist halt dieses Ding, wo man sich auch kennenlernt und auch international kennenlernt, zu so einem Ding, da kann halt wirklich jeder mitmachen. Und die Technik ist auch so einfach geworden, dass das wirklich funktioniert. Wann ist das passiert?
Also es gab immer so Schwankungen, muss ich sagen. Also es gab halt während der Gründung oder in dieser Gründungszeit zwischen 2001 und 2004, da ging das oder auch bis 2005, da ging das wahnsinnig ab. Überall sind Netze in der Republik entstanden. Wir haben ja diese Subdomains angeboten unter der Freifunknet, wo man sich halt jeder Ort sozusagen so eine eigene Subdomain registrieren konnte. Das wuchs und wuchs und wuchs und wir waren schon sehr, sehr groß. Als dann aber die Telekom anfingen DSL doch noch auszubauen in die benachteiligten Gebiete, sank das dann auch wieder so ein bisschen das Interesse, ließ dann wieder nach. Da war halt dieser Need nach diesem Internetzugang nicht mehr so gegeben. Da blieb dann eher so ein harter Kern übrig bzw. etwas anderes. Und jetzt kommt gleich Bär ins Spiel, was uns dann einen mega Schlag versetzt hat, dass es 2006 plötzlich losging mit Abmahnung und dieser ganzen Mitstörerhaftungsgeschichte.
Okay, darüber sprechen wir nach 11 Uhr. Über den ganzen juristischen Teil.
Mittlerweile. So dann war es eine ganze Zeit lang relativ ruhig, bis, danke drossel.com, danke NSA, danke all ihr Internet-Kaputtmacher da draußen. Seitdem wir diese Skandale hatten, hat Freifunk wieder extrem Zulauf und auch nicht nur diese Geschichte mit dem Internetzugang, sondern tatsächlich diese Idee des alternativen Internettes oder Netzes in dem Fall. Das Alternativnetz ist das bessere Netz, das political correcte Netz.
Ist das eigentlich ein bisschen deprimierend? Also weil sozusagen von der ideellen Idee, vom Idealismus ist das sozusagen das bessere Ding, wie du es auch gerade genannt hast. Aber die Leute kommen halt nur, wenn es tatsächlich pressiert. Man würde ja eigentlich denken, so eine Infrastruktur baut man halt dann auf, wenn es gerade allen gut geht, sieben fette Jahre und dann kommen die sieben mageren und dann hat man das halt schon. Ist das ein bisschen deprimierend, immer sozusagen dem Mangel hinterherlaufen zu müssen?
Ja, das haben wir ja öfter. Also dieser NSA-Skandal zum Beispiel, der war ja auch, also er war skandalös und überraschend, aber dann eigentlich doch nicht überraschend, weil wir es ja immer wieder propagiert haben. Und die Leute haben uns für paranoid gehalten und die Spinner und die Nerds. Und dann auf einmal ist der Schrei groß, wenn das Ganze dann doch rauskommt. Nein, wenn man so ein bisschen überlegt und sich anschaut, wie die Provider eigentlich funktionieren und wie sie zusammenhängen, dann kann man eigentlich schon im Vorfeld auf die Idee gekommen sein, dass da irgendwie ein alternatives Netz keine schlechte Idee ist.
Aber zur Frage, ob das manchmal deprimierend war, ja, war es, aber momentan, das ganze Gegenteil ist eher so, jede Woche gründet sich eine neue Community. Wir mussten Anleitungen schreiben, weil wir die gar nicht mehr, also sozusagen einzeln so, habe ich tatsächlich eine Anleitung schreiben müssen, wie gründe ich eine Community nach zehn Jahren.
Ist das irgendwie schlimm mit Vereinsmeierei, Aufriss, Amtsgericht, Notar, irgendwas?
Nein, bitte bloß gar nicht. Absolut gar nicht. Nein, also wir brauchen keinen Verein, man muss auch kein Vereinsmitglied werden, um bei Freifunk mitmachen zu können. Es gibt zwar Vereine, aber die halten sich eher im Hintergrund und sind halt als Fördervereine aufgestellt, die dann einspringen, wenn es darum geht, mal ein Event zu versichern, wenn es darum geht, Förderungsanträge zu stellen, wenn es darum geht, mit einer Stadtverwaltung oder so etwas zu verhandeln, dann ist das natürlich toller. Das ist nicht nur so eine dahergelaufene Schale von Leuten, sondern dann hat man halt so einen Verein, dann macht das durch auch Sinn, aber da tendiere ich eher dazu auch zu raten, denn wir sind gar nicht so top down oder so was organisiert. Ich kann nur beraten sozusagen, wenn jemand eine neue Community gründet, lieber so ein bisschen überregional die Vereine zu halten, um auch nicht zu viel Verwaltungsaufwand da zu erzeugen einfach, aber halt einzuhaben oder sich ein, mittlerweile gibt es wirklich einige, sich da einfach unterzuschlüpfen als Community. Und die Entscheidungen wären sowieso nicht in den Vereinen, sondern von den Communities getroffen.
Glaubst du, dass es jetzt länger anhält mit der sozusagen Begeisterungsphase?
Natürlich.
Natürlich. Gut, kommen wir zu zwei Hörerfragen, die ja aufgeschlagen sind. Das eine ist Moritz aus Bernau. Hallo und guten Abend, Moritz.
Guten Abend.
Du hast eine Frage.
Genau, ich habe eine Frage. Und zwar, wenn man dann die Daten von einer Community da rumschickt, wird das ja nicht sehr langsam?
Hm, die Alge, also ich sehe gerade ein großes Kopfschnittel. Meinst du da irgendwas Bestimmtes?
Ja, also ich kann mir das so gar nicht vorstellen, wenn man da ein Freifunknetzwerk hat und man da von einer Seite ins Internet reingeht, ob die anderen dann auch so schnell da rankommen.
Ach so, du meinst, weil da verschiedene WLAN-Geräte noch zwischen sind? Ja, also die Funklatenzen, die gibt es natürlich, die sind aber deutlich geringer als zum Beispiel die Latenz von dir über deinen normalen Provider zu irgendeinem Server. Und natürlich kommen da so ein paar Hops noch rauf, also noch so ein paar Millisekunden. Das ist aber eigentlich relativ wenig. Und diese Algorithmen, die ULSR, Batman etc. die suchen dir die optimale Route zu dem Knoten bzw. zu dem Internetzugang raus, den es gibt.
Okay, also ist das jetzt dann nicht, wenn ich da in so eine Community reingehe, elend langsam.
Das kommt natürlich darauf an, wie viele Leute den Internetzugang nutzen oder die Internetzugänge und wie viele Leute sich bereit erklärt haben, dieser Freifunk-Mesh-Wolke zur Verfügung zu stellen. Aber in aller Regel ist das nicht wirklich langsam, nein.
Also die Antwort ist, glaube ich, die sozusagen, wenn du halt irgendwie einen Kleinstadt hast von 5.000 Leuten und die teilen sich halt einen Internetanschluss, dann wird es irgendwie heikel. Aber wenn genug Bandbreite für alle da ist, also genug Internetanschlüsse, die in die Wolke reingehen oder rausgehen wieder und dann sozusagen, also rein von der Technik her ist es kein Problem, sondern nur, wenn die Endpunkte dann quasi zu knapp bemessen sind. Andersrum gefragt, falls da draußen Battlefield-Spieler gibt, die schon mal über Freifunk gezockt haben, könnt ihr gerne mal anrufen und sagen, ob das jetzt schnell genug ist oder nicht. Dann könnte man diese Frage Moritz noch ganz genau beantworten. Ansonsten alles klar, Moritz, hat das die Frage beantwortet? Sehr gut, dann viel Spaß.
Da macht es natürlich den Unterschied, ob die über das interne Freifunknetz zocken oder über das Internet in Freifunk zocken.
Das ist ja so eine Art LAN-Party, wenn man nur im Freifunk zockt.
Was hast du gegen LAN-Partys?
Nichts, ich sage nur, irgendwann hat man alle Leute besiegt und will auch mal gucken, was am Rest des Internets los ist.
Dafür gibt es Intercity-VPN. Unsere Communities sind untereinander noch verbunden.
Also man kann anscheinend Battlefield oder Call of Duty spielen, aber ich meinte natürlich im Internet, ja, Gott, nochmal. Das sind fast schon Rechtsvertreter-Tendenzen hier. Die andere Frage ist, wenn ich, also kam per Chat rein, wenn ich stelle einen WLAN-Router hin und bin sozusagen Teil dieser großen Wolke, ist das dann in irgendeiner Art und Weise gefährlicher für mich? Also man sagt ja, man lernt ja immer, wenn du dir einen Router kaufst, verschlüssel, also nimm nur deine WLAN-Verschlüsselung, weil dann bist nur du in deinem Netzwerk, es sind keine fremden Leute in deinem Netzwerk, und jetzt stelle ich halt diesen Freifunk-Router dahin, das heißt, da sind ja alle andere Leute mit bei mir im Netzwerk, ist das irgendwie gefährlich?
Das ist genauso gefährlich oder ungefährlich wie jeder andere Access-Point, den du nutzen könntest, der Telekom oder sonst etwas. Es kommt da vor allen Dingen drauf an, es gab bestimmt schon mal Sendungen über Krypto, oder?
Du meinst, du meinst, du sagst, das ist genauso gefährlich, wie wenn ich in einem öffentlichen Access-Point mich hereinsoße? Richtig.
Und das ist, da hilft dir sozusagen der Passwortschutz jetzt gar nicht, sondern es kommt eher darauf an, wenn du nicht ausgespäht werden möchtest, dann musst du halt deine Kommunikationsinhalte verschlüsseln. Und das gilt in jedem Netz auch, im Internet, und bei eben WLAN-Access-Point und auch im Freifunknetz.
Also auch wenn es kabelgebunden ist, weil da können ja immer noch Leute zwischen dir und dem Server, den du kontaktierst, sitzen. Also da sitzen ja auch mehrere Leute.
Ja, aber ich glaube, okay, das ist das eine zu sagen, also Datenverkehr immer verschlüsseln ist eine gute Idee, sagt ihr. Die andere Frage ist ja, wenn ich zu Hause beim Netzwerk bin, da hab ich ja auch Infrastruktur, also da steht keine Ahnung, mein Drucker drin und meine Xbox und mein weiß der Geier noch was. Und sozusagen, die ich möglicherweise jetzt die Angst auf, sozusagen Leute im selben Netzwerk können das dann leichter angreifen oder so.
Nein, also das Heimnetzwerk, das musst du ja nicht zur Verfügung stellen. Das bleibt ja dir überlassen. Das ist ja in aller Regel komplett abgeschottet.
Das kannst du sozusagen einstellen, welche Dienste oder welche Sachen du da freigeben willst. Da musst du halt deine Freigaben entsprechend einstellen. Du könntest natürlich auch sagen, ich habe hier meinen Daten-Server. Da liegen meine ganzen Creative Commons E-Books drauf und meine freie Musik. Und das stelle ich jetzt da im Freifunknetz zur Verfügung.
Okay, aber sagen die, wenn ich mir da so einen Huta von euch hinstelle, der von euch irgendwie präpariert wurde, dann ist das zu sagen, da haben die Leute erst mal keinen Zugang zu meinem Heimnetzwerk?
Nein.
Okay, so Robin hat angerufen, 22 aus Frankfurt, glaube ich, noch eine ganz ähnlich gehende Frage. Hallo Robin.
Hallo, ja ich habe eine Frage. Und zwar angenommen, ich würde jetzt so einen Freifunknoten betreiben, hier irgendwie bei mir zu Hause und da würden jetzt Leute sich drüber verbinden, da drüber surfen und so. Da könnte ich ja auf die Idee kommen, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Hintergedanken hätte, das alles abzuspeichern, was Leute so da über meinen Freifunknoten alles mitfotokolieren, eben irgendwie mal reinzuschauen, was da irgendwie so unter Schlüssel so abläuft. Jetzt ist es ja so, ich meine, zum Beispiel bei SSL gesicherten Verbindungen ist es ja sowieso schon gesichert, aber jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt irgendwie irgendwas im Klartext macht oder keine Ahnung, solche Geschichten, ist das technisch möglich zum einen mal, das mitzuprotokollieren, ich denke mal schon. Und gab es auch in der Vergangenheit irgendwie mal Fälle, wo Leute das irgendwie gemacht haben?
Also die Frage ist da nicht so sehr, wie ich als Betreiber sicher bin, sondern wenn ich jetzt als Nutzer so einen Freifunkfehler nutze, wie angreifbar bin ich dann oder wie abhörbar von dem Freifunkbetreiber?
Ja, also der Freifunkbetreiber, also der Knoten- und Accesspoint-Betreiber, der kann natürlich den Internetverkehr oder den gesamten Netzwerkverkehr einsehen. Aber das können halt alle Leute immer zwischen dir und dem Server, den du kontaktierst. Insofern ist das, wie Monique schon sagte, nicht sicherer oder unsicherer als alles andere auch. Du musst halt wirklich auf Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung achten hierbei.
Okay, aber das ist sozusagen wie bei, keine Ahnung, Tor oder so, wo es auch schon bekannt geworden ist, dass Leute das eben halt rein theoretisch machen können und das halt quasi einfach von Nutzer quasi selber abhängig ist, wie sehr er seine Daten quasi einfach schützt.
Genau, bei Tor zum Beispiel wird ja ein Großteil der Tor-Knoten von Geheimdiensten betrieben, damit die halt möglichst viel des Verkehrs abgreifen können, wo Leute irgendwie der Meinung sind, dafür Tor nutzen zu müssen.
Das könnten sie aber genauso gut vielleicht auch bei Freifunk machen, wenn sie sich lokal ausbreiten würden irgendwo in Berlin zum Beispiel, oder Städten, wo es halt zu größeren Lasten kommt, irgendwo an Traffic.
In der Theorie sicherlich. Wir haben aber, wie soll ich das sagen, wir sind ja sehr groß im Wert. Ich weiß das jetzt bei Tor nicht so genau, aber was ich schon sagte, auch auf diese lokale Vernetzung, wir sind auch eine soziale Community. Wir kennen uns und die Freifunker haben eigentlich alle so einen Knotenbetreiber, so eine Art Air-Kodex. Das ist natürlich eine Sache des Vertrauens. Klar, du kannst jetzt sagen, vertraue ich oder vertraue ich nicht, oder ich vertraue der Telekom mehr oder Kabel Deutschland mehr oder Tor mehr. Im Prinzip sind mir keine solche Fälle bekannt. Ganz im Gegenteil, wir diskutieren jedes Mal wieder und hartnäckig, dass wir eben Datensparsamkeit uns ganz oben auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben, wie viel Daten sind minimal nötig, um das Netzwerk aufrechtzuerhalten. Sowieso total, also es gibt ein gewisses anonymisiertes Monitoring, wo man jetzt sehen kann, wie viele Access Points sich so verbinden mit dem Knoten, damit man vielleicht auch einfach sagen kann, oh der wird nicht genutzt, dann können wir den aber anders hinstellen oder so. Da wird definitiv nichts von dem Nutzer Traffic mit geschnitten und ja, kann ich nur so stehen lassen.
Also andererseits als sicherheitsbewusster User kannst du halt sozusagen dem, also wo auch immer du dich in den W-Line einloggst, musst du dem halt, also ist bei Freifunk-Anteil nicht so, dass du dem mehr vertrauen musst, sondern das ist halt auch ein Selbstanbieter für dich als Nutzer.
Okay, gibt es denn, wenn jetzt bekannt wird, irgendwie, dass Firmen sowas, sowas macht, irgendwie, dass das mitschneidet, also gibt es irgendwie sowas wie eine Blacklist, irgendwie, dass man bestimmte Knoten ausschließen kann aus diesem Netz oder gibt es das gar nicht?
Also wir sind nicht diejenigen, die daran glauben, dass man durch technische Restriktionen soziale Probleme löst. Und insofern, wenn es Abuse gäbe, was eigentlich total selten bis eigentlich original nie vorgekommen ist, dann geht man hin und spricht mit den Leuten. Und Blacklisting wäre bestimmt nicht das erste Mittel der Wahl.
Okay, ist dabei natürlich auch ein schöner Ansatz. Das ist natürlich was anderes, wie bei Tour, wo das alles irgendwo weltweit verteilt ist und man eben schlecht irgendwo zu einem Serverbetreiber hingehen kann und sagen kann, hey hör mal bitte auf hier alles mitzuschneiden.
So deine Fragen beantwortet Robin? Alles klar, dann viel Spaß. Bist du selber Freifunker?
Noch nicht, aber ich überleg's mir ehrlich gesagt gerade. Ich hab nur das mit dem VPN noch nicht gewusst und hatte immer so ein bisschen Bedenken, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so einen Freifunkrouter aufstelle bei mir irgendwo. Also ich wohne in Frankfurt, das ist ja auch relativ zentral und jemand betreibt dann irgendwie Missbrauch, werbt sich irgendwelche illegalen Filmchen runter.
Ich kann nur sagen, bleib dran, darum geht es in dieser Sendung auch noch und zwar gleich. Hallo, guten Abend und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaosradio auf Fritz im Blue Moon am 31. Juli, kurz nach 11, wo wir heute über Freifunk und Störerhaftung reden wollen. Um Freifunk ging es schon die ganze erste Stunde. Wir haben geklärt, das ist so eine mehr oder weniger technisch-soziale Art, kleine WLAN-Router miteinander zu verbinden, vielleicht auch größere und so Netzwerk herzustellen, das man benutzen kann. Man kann damit Internet teilen, Daten, vielleicht auch Gedanken. Also es ist tatsächlich eine andere Art und Möglichkeit, sozusagen Netz möglichst vielen Leuten zur Verfügung zu stellen. Die Idee kam ein bisschen daher, dass man Internetanschlüsse weiter teilt, aber mittlerweile hat sich so eine Art alternatives Angebot etabliert, wo man zum Beispiel auch so Überwachungen so ein bisschen umgehen kann. Und mit dabei sind Monique und Mirko, die auch die erste Stunde quasi bestritten haben in der Eingang. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal.
Hallo.
Und dann haben wir Rechtsanwältin Bea Hubrich hier. Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Die jetzt wahrscheinlich den Rest bestreiten wird. Wollen wir mal sehen. Robin hatte gerade angerufen und hat, hat sozusagen genau die Frage gestellt, die jetzt sozusagen wie von Zauberhamt in den nächsten Teil der Sendung passt, nämlich, dass dieses Freifunk-Prinzip, das haben wir geklärt, basiert darauf, dass sich viele Leute zusammentun. Das heißt auch, dass ich, der ich einen Internetanschluss habe und mir so einen Freifunkrouter hinstelle, meinen Anschluss mit ganz vielen anderen Leuten teile. Und dann kann es natürlich passieren, dass irgendwelche Leute hingehen, sich in den Router einloggen, der von mir betrieben wird über meinen Internetanschluss oder da ankommen über andere Freifunkstrecken und dann irgendwelchen blödsinnigen Kram machen, der vielleicht kriminell ist oder Schweinkram oder weiß ja gar ja was. Und dann bin ich als Anschlussinhaber dran.
Willkommen in Deutschland.
So, Frau Hubrich, es gibt ja etwas, das heißt und das hat man vielleicht tatsächlich auch schon mal in den Nachrichten gehört, weil das ist in den letzten, ich weiß nicht, Jahren sogar schon immer mal wieder Thema gewesen, zumindest in diesen Netzthemenkreisen, die sogenannte Störerhaftung.
Die Störerhaftung ist seit 2006 Thema. Da gab es ein berühmtes Hamburger Urteil und danach haftet der Anschlussinhaber für etwaigig begangene Urheberrechtsverletzungen und muss teilweise nicht unerhebliche Summen an Verwerter zahlen.
Also jemand anderes legt über mein Wille einen illegalen Song runter oder hoch ist ja meistens das Problem?
Ja, ich versuche mich da irgendwie so ein bisschen einzuschränken. Also ich könnte aus dem, was du da angesprochen hast, ganz viele juristische Baustellen aufmachen und besprechen. Das ist auch mal wichtig, dass wir darüber reden. Aber du kannst mich stoppen oder ein bisschen leiten. Ich würde erstmal grundsätzlich damit anfangen. Wenn jemand abgemahnt wird, dann gibt es da in dem Abmahlschreiben, also wenn es einigermaßen sauber gemacht wird von den Abmahlanwälten, die IP-Adresse mit dem dazugehörigen Beschluss von dem Landgericht Köln oder München oder Ähnlichem. Also kommt drauf an, Telekom oder O2, wo man Kunde ist. Und mit diesem Beschluss und der IP-Adresse wird davon ausgegangen, dass der Anschlussinhaber da eine Urheberrechtsverletzung gegangen hat. Und hier an diesem wirklich ersten Punkt entstehen schon sehr große Zweifel. Nummer eins handelt es sich tatsächlich um eine Urheberrechtsverletzung. Also war es eine Datei, die geschützt war tatsächlich auch hier in unserem Kulturkreis. Und die zweite Frage ist die Protokollierung auch wirklich korrekt gewesen. Also die IP-Adresse, die da kommuniziert hat, ist das auch wirklich die, die dann dem Anschlussinhaber zu dem Zeitpunkt zugeordnet war?
Das ist schon wieder viel komplizierter, als ich eigentlich dachte, dass überhaupt Leute besprechen werden. Lass mich versuchen, das nochmal zu verstehen. Also wenn es um eine Abmahnung geht wegen Filesharing, dann wird diese Abmahnung dadurch ausgelöst, dass die Leute, die glauben, die Recht an der Datei inne zu haben, versucht haben herauszuwinden, von welchem Internetanschluss diese Urheberrechtsverletzung durchgeführt wurde. Das heißt, wer zur Hölle hat da nochmal Filesharing gemacht? Dadurch stellen sie sagen, in dem Filesharing-Protokoll, Tauschbörse, wie auch immer, fest, welche IP-Nummer verwendet wurde. Und daraus kann man dann Rückschlüsse ziehen, welcher Internetanschluss das war.
Theoretisch, so ist die Idee, die dahintersteht.
So ist die Idee, die dahintersteht. Man kann diese ersten beiden Dinge schon anzweifeln. Also ob überhaupt das, worum es dagegen überrechtlich geschützt ist und dann, ob das überhaupt richtig ermittelt wurde. Ich frage mich jetzt aber, ist das jetzt relevant für die Freifunk-Debatte?
Naja, also ich komme da sogar noch zu anderen Punkten. Also es geht bei Abmahnungen nicht nur um die Störerhaftung. Wir kommen da hin und wir haben eine ganze Stunde Zeit. Aber es gibt da mehrere Punkte bei diesen Abmahnungen, die fragwürdig sind. Und es beginnt schon bei der Protokollierung der AIP-Adressen beim Provider. Ob das alles so sauber und korrekt passiert ist. Es gab noch kein Verfahren, also ein Gerichtsverfahren, wo ein Provider geladen wurde oder ebenfalls Mitarbeiter von einem Provider und gesagt hat, ich soll das Mikrofon knutschen, sagt der Monoxy, ich bemühe mich. Ja, die Protokollierung ist beweisfest. Ja, die AIP-Adresse, die jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt protokolliert hat, ist auch tatsächlich dann dem Anschlussinhaber zu dem Zeitpunkt zugewiesen worden. Das ist die erste Frage. Damit will ich sagen, dass viele Anschlussinhaber abgemahnt wurden und gezahlt haben, ohne dass wirklich feststand, dass von diesem Anschluss diese Rechtsverletzung auch begangen wurde. Das ist der erste Punkt. Wollen wir über den hinweggehen?
Wir reden jetzt über eine Sache, die mit diesem Prinzip, dass ich für die Taten anderer verantwortlich gemacht werden kann, eigentlich nichts zu tun hat.
Naja, es geht um Abmahnung generell. Die Störerhaftung ist ein Teil von einer Abmahnung. Das Problem bei Freifunkern ist, dass eine Haftungsgefahr besteht. Und zwar dadurch, dass man eine Abmahnung von Anwälten in den Briefkasten bekommt und aufgefordert wird, eine Unterlassungserklärung abzugeben mit einer bestimmten Summe, die man zu zahlen hat. Das ist das Problem, was Freifunker haben können.
Hat nicht jeder.
Wenn sie den Internet Zugang zur Verfügung stellen.
Ich wollte die ganze Zeit nochmal wieder einhaken. Mir geht es um den Teil vom Freifunk, wo ich meinen Anschluss anderen Leuten frei zur Verfügung stelle, also einen freien Internetzugang haben. Und das hat nicht, wie Monique gesagt hat, das Ganze getunnelt wird, sondern durch einen deutschen Provider rausgeht. Darüber spreche ich jetzt hier und genau da ist Störerhaftung. In anderen Fällen habe ich ja die Störerhaftung nicht. Aber hinter der Störerhaftung steckt eben eine Abmahnung. Ich bekomme eine Abmahnung und da gibt es mehrere Teile, zum Beispiel eben auch die Täterschaft. Also man wird immer wieder darüber hinweggegangen und es wird immer nur thematisiert, dass das Problem nicht Störerhaftung ist. Aber was größer ist, ist die Täterschaft. Das heißt, erst mal wird dem Anschlussinhaber vorgeworfen, in diesem Abmahn schreiben, dass er eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen hat und dass er für diese Urheberrechtsverletzung Schadensersatz zahlen muss. Und erst wenn er nachweisen kann, dass er selber nicht Täter war, kommt man auf die zweite Ebene der Störerhaftung. Störerhaftung bedeutet, ich habe daran teilgenommen, dass jemand eine Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen hat. Und ich habe vorher noch versucht zu erklären, dass es oft strittig ist oder man das auch mal diskutieren muss, dass überhaupt diese Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen wurde und Nummer zwei auch überhaupt von diesem Internetanschluss. Also Störerhaftung ist sozusagen die vierte Stufe bei diesen Abmahnungen.
Dann machen wir es jetzt wie du willst und zwar der Reihe nach. So, warum ist es, wie kann überhaupt angezweifelt werden, dass die pfeilgescherte Datei überhaupt urheberrechtlich geschützt ist?
Weil nicht alle Dateien, die man tauscht, urheberrechtlich geschützt sind. Die können dir ja irgendwas erzählen.
Wenn aber sozusagen eine Abmahnkanzlei losgeht und sozusagen Leute abmahnt wegen Pfeilschering, müssen die doch irgendwie sicherstellen, weswegen die abmahnen oder nicht? Die können auch nicht einfach überhaupt sagen, hier, du hast was Falsches gemacht.
Aber das passiert doch ständig.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Also Leute gehen vor Gericht, aber so funktionieren doch Rechtsstreitigkeiten. Der eine wirft dem anderen etwas vor, dass du hier rechtlich was falsch gemacht hast und es muss geklärt werden, ob das stimmt.
Ja klar, aber sozusagen ein Abmahnanwalt kann wegen Pfeilschering doch nur abmahnen, wenn ein urheberrechtlich geschütztes Werk vorliegen hat, wo seine Lakaien festgestellt haben, dass es in irgendeiner Tauschbörse aufgetauscht ist.
Das sind Drittdienstleister, die für die arbeiten. Und das ist alles nicht so wahnsinnig sauer, was da passiert. Wenn ein Anwalt behauptet, dass jemand anderes eine Rechtsverletzung begangen hat, ist es nicht automatisch so, dass derjenige die Rechtsverletzung begangen hat, sondern das muss erst mal kontrolliert werden. Und deshalb haben wir bestimmte Regelungen, Beweisregelungen vor Gericht, dass es überprüft wird, was vor Vorwürfe eben von einem Anwalt dann damit geteilt wurde.
Ich kann jetzt natürlich wieder nur meine Privatstatistik anbringen. Jedes Mal, wenn ich sozusagen von Abmahnungen gehört habe, dann waren es gingstattdessen sagen Umwerke, die auch überrichtlich geschützt waren tatsächlich.
Aber zum Beispiel gab es ja auch Fälle, wo Leute ihr WLAN verschlüsselt haben, im Urlaub waren und in dieser Zeit angeblich was...
Doch, das ist genau richtig, was Möko anspricht. Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung.
Es geht jetzt gerade, du hast gesagt, der erste Punkt ist, dass man gar nicht genau weiß, ob die Datei, wegen der abgemahnt wird, überhaupt urheberrechtlich geschützt ist.
Das ist einfach nur behauptet, ich kriege einen Brief und da steht es...
Entschuldigung, es geht doch erst mal darum, überhaupt, du hast doch gesagt, das ist das Problem, dass man gar nicht weiß, ob diese Datei wirklich urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Und das frage ich jetzt, wie sowas passieren kann. Weil die Fälle, von denen ich immer gehört habe, also abgesehen davon, was dahinter immer noch alles passieren kann ist. Wieso könnt ihr denn auf die Idee kommen, wegen einer Datei abzumachen, die gar nicht urheberrechtlich geschützt ist? Das ist ja das, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Also ich denke, es ist einfach auch eine ganz typische und ganz normale juristische, sozusagen von Juristen vorgehensweise, immer erst mal, sozusagen man arbeitet sich da von vorne nach hinten sozusagen durch und prüft erst mal, ist das überhaupt richtig? Ist dieses Abmahnschreiben überhaupt formal richtig verfasst? Wenn nicht, Mülleimer. Ist denn das überhaupt hier jetzt tatsächlich eine uhrhebergeschützte Datei? Wenn nicht, irgendwie Mülleimer. Ist denn das überhaupt mit dem Protokollieren der IP-Adresse blablabla und so gehst du so durch und kannst natürlich jeden Punkt anzweifeln.
Ja genau, das ist die Frage, ob das überhaupt Sinn macht in dem Fall. Also gibt es tatsächlich Abmahnungen wegen Dateien, die gar nicht uhrberechtlich geschützt sind?
Klar, warum nicht?
Genauso wie es Abmahnungen gegen Leute gab, die halt gar nicht zu der Zeit das Internet nutzen konnten, weil sie im Urlaub waren, dass wir dann verschlüsselt haben. Die arbeiten einfach nicht zwangsläufig sauber.
Es ist eine Industrie, die Geld macht, indem sie wie wie früher Notare schicken, die jetzt diese Abmahnbriefe raus, zack, die boom. Das ist also ganz oft ist noch nicht mal eine Vollmacht von dem Rechteverwerter drinnen. Darüber haben sie sich auch Jahre vor Gericht gestritten, ob diese Vollmacht von einem Rechteverwerter drinnen sein muss. Haben die Gerichte gesagt, nein, muss nicht. Das heißt, sowas kriege ich erst in einem Gerichtsverfahren überprüft und meine Pflicht ist es, zu kontrollieren, dass diese Vollmacht vorliegt, zu kontrollieren, dass dieses Werk überrechtlich zu diesem Zeitpunkt an diesem Ort geschützt ist. Es kann ja sein, dass es in den USA geschützt ist, aber in Deutschland, in Europa nicht. Das sind so Punkte, die ich kontrollieren muss.
Und das sind... Ich, wer ist das dann?
Der Abgemahnte. Das heißt, wenn mir jemand eine Rechtsverletzung vorwirft, muss ich den ganzen Weg, so wie Monique das nochmal wiederholt hat, muss ich kontrollieren, stimmt das eigentlich, was mir hier vorgeworfen wird? Und die Störerhaftung ist der letzte Punkt, den ich mir angucke. Zuerst guck ich mir das an, ist das wirklich ein urheberrechtlich gestütztes Werk? Am besten... Also das kann ich alles nur vor Gericht machen. Außergerichtlich haben die das so erkämpft in den letzten acht Jahren, dass sie kaum wirklich Sachen außergerichtlich vorlegen müssen. Also dass sie die Vollmacht nicht vorlegen müssen. Dass sie nicht nachweisen müssen, dass es wirklich urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Zum Beispiel. Da steht auch in den Abmalenschriften drin. Wir verweisen auf das und das Urteil. Wir müssen das außergerichtlich nicht mehr vorlegen. Das heißt, sie können mit Prozess, also Gefahr, dass ich das Ganze verliere, sie können vor Gericht gegen uns gehen und dann legen wir das erst vor und dann kontrollieren wir das. Was ich sagen will, ist, dass diese Abmahnung an mehreren Punkten wirklich hinken. Nicht erst bei der Störerhaftung, wo wir hoffentlich noch mal hinkommen und darüber dann sprechen, sondern die Abmahnung an sich muss man rechtlich in mehreren Punkten kontrollieren und überprüfen, ob das alles so in Ordnung ist.
Aber du sagst ja auch, vieles davon kann ich gar nicht ohne Prozessrisiko prüfen. Was kann ich denn ohne Prozessrisiko jetzt prüfen?
Einmal die Täterschaft. Das heißt, dann komme ich aus dem Vorwurf heraus, dass ich selber diese Überrechtsverletzung begangen habe. Komme ich da nicht raus, dann besteht die Gefahr, dass die sogenannte Lizenz-Analogie angewendet wird. Das heißt, Schadensersatz muss ich in Höhe von einer angeblichen Lizenz zahlen.
Also Täterschaft heißt sozusagen, wenn ich die Abmahnung kriege, wirft mir die Abmahnung ja quasi vor, du warst es. Du hast das zu sagen, du bist der Täter, du bist der Täter des Fall-Sharing. Ich prüfe die Täterschaft, stelle fest, ich war das nicht. Und dann? Also sage ich dann, ich war es nicht? Oder wie funktioniert diese Prüfung meiner Täterschaft?
Ich muss es beweisen können.
Wie mache ich das denn?
Entweder war ich nicht da, ich war im Urlaub, was total super wäre.
Passiert manchmal, aber wahrscheinlich nicht so häufig?
Wahrscheinlich nicht so häufig. Ich bin ausgegangen oder ich hatte Freunde da.
Also da stehen dann Uhrzeiten richtig mit dran, oder wie?
Genau, genau, richtig der Zeitraum, wo das hochgeladen worden ist. Und dieser Punkt ist wichtig. Der ist sogar wichtiger als die Störerhaftung, weil da mehr Geld dahinter steckt.
Okay, also wenn die Abmahnanwälte sagen, wenn ich ihnen nichts beweisen kann, dass ich es nicht war, also nicht konkret selber war, der da was hochgeladen hat, dann könnte es unter Umständen teuer werden. Wie ist es denn jetzt? Ich war zu dem Zeitpunkt zu Hause, aber ich habe es trotzdem nicht gemacht. Was denn dann?
Dann hast du seit diesem Jahr Glück. Es gibt eine neue Bewegung in der Rechtsprechung, und zwar die Annahme, dass ein Anschlussinhaber gleich der Verletzer, der rechte Verletzer ist, wackelt. Die Rechtsprechung ging jetzt jahrelang davon aus, dass Internetanschlüsse nicht geteilt werden oder zu einem sehr geringen Prozentsatz.
Da kommt dann auf diese Idee, das sind doch nur so komische Hippies wie die Freifunkern.
Also die meisten Leute leben dann eben alleine in ihrer Wohnung und haben keine Freunde und hocken da und mein Internet.
Aber dann ist diese Theaterschaft dann doch nicht mehr so hart.
Das ist ein Amtsgerichtsurteil aus München, wo wir wirklich sehr glücklich sind, dass es das jetzt gibt.
Aber das ist einmal so entschieden worden. Das heißt, das ist noch nicht...
Das dauert halt ein bisschen, bis so die Gerichtsbarkeit die Realität erkennt, dass ja schon seit Jahren Anschlüsse mehrfach genutzt werden in Familien durch Freunde oder durch andere.
Aber was heißt das dann jetzt konkret?
Dass ich dann, wenn ich nicht beweisen kann...
Also nochmal sagen, ich kann wirklich nur beweisen, in Anführungszeichen, dass ich es nicht war, wenn ich nicht an dem Ort war, wo der Internetrouter steht.
Mit dem...
Ist eine Frage.
Ja, also es gibt ganz unterschiedliche Urteile. Erstmal grundsätzlich ja, wenn ich beweisen kann, dass ich mit Person B in Südamerika, in Argentinien unterwegs gewesen bin, dann wird mir das Gericht glauben, dass ich diese Urheberrechtsverletzung nicht begangen habe.
Okay, so, das gibt aber keine Möglichkeit, wenn ich zu dem Zeitpunkt, der in der Abmahlung steht, zu Hause war, alleine an meinem Rechner, dann kann ich halt nicht sagen, ich war es nicht, sondern dann hat der Abmahnanwalt erst mal recht.
Na, erst mal, das wird alles ein bisschen offener zurzeit. Und zwar, wenn da jetzt noch Mitbewohner sind, oder wenn ich mit meiner Familie dann da lebe. Also ich wohne komplett alleine da und habe mein Internet geschlossen.
Wenn du es geschlossen hast, reden wir davon, dass dein Internetanschluss verschlüsselt war? Oder reden wir davon, dass dein Internetanschluss offen zur Verfügung gestellt wurde?
Nee, ich bin kein Freifunk.
Dann bist du Täter, in deinem Fall. Genau, das ist diese, also du musst, also ich kann jetzt mit juristischen Wörtern um mich schlagen. Lass dich jetzt mal. Du musst irgendwie, wenn du diesen, das ist anerkannt von Rechtsprechung, dass einem Anschlussinhaber dieser Vorwurf gemacht werden kann. Was wirklich fragwürdig ist und was ich am Anfang schon erwähnt habe. Und wenn du keine Fakten hast, die du vor Gericht beweisen kannst, dass du nicht der Einzige bist, der das nutzt, dann bist du Täter. Und du wirst die Lizenzen für dieses urheberrechtlich geschützte Werk als Schadensersatz zahlen müssen.
Was heißt, also wie beweist sich das noch jemand anderes, was Internet nutzt?
Also WG-Mitbewohner zum Beispiel, Familien, also diejenigen, die bei dir in dem Haus leben.
Muss ich dann beweisen, dass die zu dem Zeitpunkt auch da war?
Ja, du musst die tatsächliche Möglichkeit, dass andere dieses Internet mitgenutzt haben, zu dem Zeitpunkt, also zu dem Tatzeitpunkt nachweisen können vor Gericht. Und zwar so glaubwürdig, dass du den Richter davon überzeugen kannst, dass du zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht der Einzige warst, der das benutzen konnte.
Und was heißt das dann? Dann ist automatisch der andere schuld?
Nein, nein, nein. Dann kommst du aus der Täterschaft raus. Das geht in dem Moment. Du bist der Abgemahnte und du bist der Beklagte.
Dann geht es erst mal nur darum, ob ich es war oder nicht.
Genau. Und wenn du es nicht warst, wenn du beweisen kannst, dass du nicht Täter warst, dann kommen wir zur Störerhaft.
Ich kann ja noch nicht beweisen, dass ich nicht Täter war. Ich kann nur beweisen, dass noch jemand anders auch da war.
Das reicht.
Das reicht erst mal.
Also Leute, haltet euch einen Mitbewohner.
Genau. Ich kann nicht für alle Gerichte sprechen.
Oder macht euer Netz auf.
So, das heißt, dann habe ich gesagt so, ja, ich hatte aber noch jemand anderes Zugriff gehabt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ich kann es also nicht gewesen sein.
Es ist noch die ernsthafte Möglichkeit, dass jemand anderes diese Rechtsverletzung begangen hat.
Also das reicht als Möglichkeit sozusagen. Und dann bin ich aber so, dann bin ich raus als Täter. Also dann kann man mir nicht mal vorwerfen, okay, du warst es aber, sondern dann bin ich aber möglicherweise noch störerhaft. Störer, was ist ein Störer?
Ein Störer ist jemand, der sich an einer Rechtsverletzung beteiligt.
Moment mal, ich habe mein Internet-Dings mit anderen Leuten geteilt und da habe ich doch nichts mitgemacht. Also ich war doch nur an meinem Rechner, habe Comics gelesen und der andere hat Gefeilschert. Wieso bin ich da beteiligt juristisch?
Mitstörer heißt das doch sogar ganz korrekt oder?
Du kannst doch durch Unterlassen Störer sein. Also du musst nicht immer nur aktiv irgendjemanden unterstützen, also du musst nicht irgendjemanden bewusst fördern, sagen, hey guck mal hier ist irgendwie auf der und der Website, kannst du da diesen tollen Film angucken, musst du dir aber irgendwie runterladen, ich glaube das Illiga und tralala. Also du musst halt da nicht irgendwie aktiv auf jemanden einwirken, sondern das reicht das Passive und zwar, wenn du jemand anderen in dein Wirkfeld reinlässt, sozusagen eben deinen Anschluss zur Verfügung stellst, dann bist du dann daran beteiligt. Um das mal klar zu machen.
Das heißt, ich nehme mein Internet, mache das auf und stehe nicht die ganze Zeit hinter dem anderen, der das auch noch sagt, nein, du darfst nicht falsch hören, dann bin ich sozusagen Störer.
Ja, schon vorher, in dem Moment, wo du es aufmachst. Also in dem Moment, wenn du dafür sorgst, dass deine Mitbewohner, deine Familie, deine Freunde das Internet mitbenutzen und da irgendetwas passiert, bist du daran beteiligt, weil es dein Anschluss ist. Weil du das nicht unterlassen hast, dafür zu sorgen, dass es nicht passiert.
Das ist nicht ganz so teuer, wie wenn ich Täter wäre, aber es kostet immer noch Geld.
Genau, das ist nicht ganz so teuer, da kann man so mal eins, zwei Nullen wegmachen.
Das ist aber natürlich der Punkt, wo ich sage, naja, wenn ich das für meine WG aufmache, dann kann ich jedem einzelnen die Warte geben und sagen, nee, machen wir hier keinen Fallscheren. Aber wenn ich das jetzt für Freifunk aufmache, dann kann ja jeder, also nicht nur die Leute, die in meinem WLAN drin sind, sondern auch noch die Leute, die dadurch, dass mein WLAN ja mit anderen WLANs verknüpft ist und sozusagen eigentlich ganz viele Leute über meinen Internetanschluss Dinge tun können, da laufe ich ja quasi, also statistisch gesehen, in Gefahr, dass es auf jeden Fall irgendwann mal passiert.
Statistisch gesehen, ja.
Das spricht jetzt nicht so richtig für Freifunk.
Es spricht generell nicht dafür, dass man sein Internet aufmacht.
Eigentlich möchte ich meinen WG-Mitbewohnern sagen, nee, auch meiner Familie nicht, holt mal bitte euren eigenen Anschluss.
Genau, also auch Leute, die mir nahe stehen, mit denen ich gerne irgendwie meine Werte, die ich besitze, teile. Die Störerhaftung an sich ist im Urheberrecht umstritten. Die Störerhaftung ist außerhalb des Urheberrechts gar keine schlechte Idee. Das ist auch altes, altes Zivilrecht. Wir lernen im Studium, dass mit dem Beispiel, ich besitze ein Grundstück neben einem anderen Grundstück und mein Nachbar, der hatte auch ein schönes Haus. Und auf meinem Grundstück ist ein Baum, eine riesengroße Kiefer stattlich. Und beim letzten Gewitter hat so ein bisschen was abgekommen. Und jetzt besteht die Gefahr, dass diese Kiefer umkippt und direkt auf das Haus des Nachbarn. Der Nachbar sieht es. Der kann ja natürlich nicht auf mein Grundstück und diese Kiefer einfach wegmachen lassen. Kostet auch einen Heidengeld. Aber er kann mich als Störer heranziehen. Das heißt, er kann von mir verlangen, dass ich diese Kiefer sicher. Sodass diese Gefahr des Umkippens auf sein Haus nicht mehr gibt. Ist eine gute Idee. Also wenn ich bestimmte Sachen betreibe, wie zum Beispiel ein Auto, was anerkanntermaßen ein Werkzeug ist, was Leben gefährden kann und das auch tut. Oder ein AKW oder ähnliches. Ich muss dafür sorgen, dass von diesen Gefahrenzonen keine Schäden ausgehen.
Okay, aber jetzt ist sozusagen ein Villernrouter weder ein AKW noch eine Kiefer.
Korrekt.
Glauben manche Leute. Aber es hat sich sozusagen noch nicht so ganz durchgesetzt.
Genau. Das Internet ist keine Gefahrenzone.
Mein Lieblingssatz. Ist es nicht. Und zwar, weil es sich ja nur um einen Reinkommunikations- oder Informationsmittel handelt, genauso wie wenig von einem Telefon die Gefahr ausgeht oder von einem Briefkasten, sondern nur, wie ich es nutze. Also ich bin oder vergleichbar mit einer Autobahn. Die Autobahn an sich, wenn die da ist, ist unproblematisch. Also da wird jetzt niemand sterben. Aber wenn jemand ein Auto so gegen eine Person verwendet, dass sie verletzt werden kann, dann haben wir ein Problem. Also nicht die Autobahn und nicht Internet ist hier gefährlich, sondern wie bestimmte Personen die Autobahn oder das Internet nutzen oder womit. Diese Unterscheidung wird leider nicht vorgenommen.
So, aber wenn ich die Richter schiehe, ist es so. Ihr denkt, ja, das ist alles nicht so schlimm. Und mit der Störerhaftung, das ist großer Quatsch. Juristische Realität ist gerade eine andere.
Na, die verändert sich ja gerade so ein bisschen.
Genau, die Auseinandersetzung rechtlich, ob Internet tatsächlich eine Gefahrenzone ist. Also die Frage wurde jetzt rechtlich nicht erörtert, sondern das wurde halt angenommen. Und zwar mit der Begründung, dass eben so viele Rechte von Verwertungsinhabern verletzt wurden. Sie kommen da mit enormen Summen, die sie in den 90er Jahren verdient haben. Mit den Summen standen sie vor Gericht und haben rumgeheult. Das ist unfassbar, wie viel Geld uns hier geklaut wird. Wir müssen irgendwas tun. Und zwar tut man auch nichts gegen die Provider, sondern man tut etwas gegen die Anschlussinhaber, also den letzten Beißen die Hunde. Das hat sich auch rein in einer Rechtsprechung entwickelt, dieses Problem. Es betrifft uns in Deutschland im Moment immer noch. Wir sind in guter Hoffnung, dass es wie in anderen Ländern, zum Beispiel in den USA, dieses Problem nicht mehr besteht.
Oder auch in anderen europäischen Nachbarländern, in die wir zum Beispiel VPN-Tunnel mit dem Freifunk haben, um genau dieser deutschen spannenden Rechtsprechung sozusagen da zu entgehen.
Also das ist der eine Punkt, wenn man Freifunk benutzt, kann man das so einstellen, dass wenn Leute meinen Internetanschluss benutzen, gar nicht sozusagen für Deutsch, also in Deutschland sichtbar sind, sondern erst irgendwie in Schweden oder anderen Ländern rauskommt. Und dann ist das sozusagen eine technische Umgehung dieser juristischen Gefahr. Aber die kann ja auch schiefgehen zum Beispiel.
Ja, da kann technisch irgendwie mal was nicht klappen.
So und dann ist halt die Frage, ich komme immer noch nicht an den Punkt, weil ihr gesagt habt, so also diese Störerhaftung, das ist eigentlich Blödsinn, aber de facto scheint es gerade noch anders zu sein. Wir werden das in der letzten halben Stunde noch klären. Jetzt machen wir erst mal die Nachrichten. Bis gleich.
Egal ob als Sänger, oder Komponist, oder Produzent. Alles, was er anfasst, wird zu Gold. Also Vorsicht, lasst euch lieber nicht von ihm anfassen. Aber angucken könnt ihr ihn ruhig.
Fritz präsentiert.
Dienstag, 16. September. Ferrell Williams, live in der Max Schmeling-Halle.
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation will mehr tun, um die Ebola Epidemie in Westafrika an den Griff zu bekommen. Die WHO teilte am Abend mit, dass sie ein Notfallprogramm in Höhe von 100 Millionen Dollar auflegt. Morgen soll es dazu einen Krisegipfel der betroffenen Länder in Guinea geben. Guinea ist selbst von der Ebola Epidemie betroffen, genauso wie Sierra Leone und Liberia. Bisher wurden laut WHO mehr als 1.300 Menschen angesteckt, über die Hälfte von ihnen starb. Der Berliner Bezirk Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg muss den Polizeieinsatz an der besetzten Gerthauptmannschule nicht bezahlen. Insenator Henkel sagte in der RBB-Abendschau, dass es nach rechtlicher Prüfung keine Möglichkeit gibt, den Bezirk in Regress zu nehmen. Deshalb müsse die Polizei die Kosten tragen. Henkel selbst findet das falsch. Er warf Bezirksbürgermeisterin Hermann vor, den Einsatz durch ihre Entscheidungsfeigheit in die Länge gezogen zu haben. Dadurch, dass er gut eine Woche gedauert hat, liegen alleine die Personalkosten bei 5 Mio. Euro. Berlins Justizsenator Heilmann ist erleichtert, dass jetzt auch der zweite entflohene Häftling aus der JVA-Morbid wieder gefasst ist. Dem RBB sagte er, dass er der Polizei und den Strafverfolgungsbehörden sehr dankbar ist. Das SEK stellte den 2. Gefängnisausbrecher am Nachmittag in einer Wohnung in Reinickendorf. Sein Komplizen hatte die Polizei schon Anfang Juni in einem Berliner Hotel festgenommen. Beide Männer waren im Mai aus dem Gefängnis in Morbit abgehauen. Sie zersägten die Gitterstäbe ihrer Zellen, seilten sich ab und bezwangen eine Mauer und Stacheldraht. Die deutschen U19-Fußballer sind Europameister geworden. Die DFB-Auswahl besiegte am Abend im Finale in Budapest Portugal mit 1 zu 0. Damit holten die deutschen Junioren nach 1981 und 2008 zum dritten Mal den Titel. Den Siegtreffer erzielte Mukta von Hertha BSC in der 39. Minute. Das Wetter Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Marzahn haben wir 14 Grad, im Rheinikendorf noch 19, Ziesa 16, Angermünde 17, Frankfurt 18 und Falkensee 19 Grad. In der Nacht soll es trocken bleiben, bei 16 bis 13 Grad minimal. Morgen wird es dann wärmer, als es heute war. Wir kriegen 28 Grad, viel Sonne und, so weit es man das sagen kann, kein Regen. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Friedrichshain, Karl-Marx-Allee, zwischen Warschauer und Lichtenberger Straße wegen der Biermeile bis Montagabendeinschränkungen Richtung Alexanderplatz. Und zur S-Bahn, zwischen Friedrichstraße und Zoologischem Garten fahren noch bis Montag früh Busse. Alternativ könnt ihr auch auf Regionalbahn umsteigen und ab Montag ist dann der Bereich zwischen Ostbahnhof und Friedrichstraße gesperrt. Wochermehr seid, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des AirBB.
Und wenn ihr wissen wollt, was heute Morgen bei den Radio-Fritzen am Morgen so los und wichtig war, dann fritz.de slash heute Morgen.
Und dann haben wir an dieser Stelle im Chaosradio noch eine kleine Nerd-News vorgetragen, mitgebracht. Und tatsächlich könnte man an dieser Stelle auch sagen, verursacht von Bea Rubrich, Rechtsanwältin. Hallo und guten Abend. Sie müssten ihr Mikrofon möglicherweise, dann kann man sie auch hören.
Hallo.
Sehr schön. Apple hat Angst vor Ihnen, warum?
Ja, ich glaube, Apple hat tatsächlich Angst zumindest vor einem Urteil. Sie haben am 23.07.2014, also jetzt gerade, ihre Berufung gegen ein 1. 20. ergangenes Urteil zurückgenommen.
Worum geht es, Herrgott, nochmal?
Und zwar Mitarbeiter-Bewachung, Mitarbeiter-Überwachung, illegale Mitarbeiter-Überwachung im Back-of-House. Es gibt in diesen Apple-Läden, Apple-Stores, Mensch, Apple-Läden gibt es einen Back-of-House und einen Front-of-House. Im Front-of-House sind die ganzen Sachen ausgestellt. Da kommen die Kunden hin und gucken sich die Produkte an und kaufen sie. Und im Back-of-House gibt es Genius-Room und Managementraum, wo man sich umzieht etc. Und diese Back-of-House ist nicht für Kunden geöffnet, sondern nur für Mitarbeiter und in diesen Räumlichkeiten sind Rundkameras. Und diese Überwachung durch die Rundkameras wurde vom Arbeitsgericht Frankfurt am Main für rechtswidrig erklärt. Dagegen hat Apple Berufung eingelegt und einen Tag vor dem Urteil über die Berufung haben sie die Berufung wieder zurückgenommen.
Das heißt, Apple ist sozusagen dafür verurteilt worden, dass sie in den Hinterräumen Mitarbeiter wieder überwacht haben?
Genau, dieses Urteil ist jetzt rechtskräftig und sie müssen Schmerzensgeld in Höhe von 3500 Euro an den Kläger zahlen.
Wird das Konsequenzen haben? Weit reichendere? So was wie, die bauen jetzt alle Videokameras ab? Na gut, schauen wir mal. Später dazu mehr. Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Heute mit dem Chaos Computer Club und anverwandten Sympathisanten von den Freifunkern. Da sind Mirko, Monique und Bea. Hallo und guten Abend.
Na Abend.
So, wir haben eineinhalb Stunden hinter uns. Es war ein wilder Ritt. Wir haben erklärt, was Freifunk überhaupt ist, nämlich eine Technologie und eine Initiative, um Internet für alle möglich zu machen, also auf eine Art und Weise, die weniger überwacht ist, die vielleicht sogar schneller ist und die dicke Anschlüsse überall hinbringt. Und sind dann in der zweiten Stunde dahin gekommen, dass es so ein juristisches Problem gibt, was generell im Internet existiert, wo man aber als Freifunk möglicherweise auch reinrutschen kann, wenn die Technik mal versagt. Und wo jetzt sozusagen, es gibt eine Störerhaftung. Kannst du noch mal ganz kurz Bea erklären, was Störerhaftung ist? Ganz, ganz kurz.
Störerhaftung bedeutet, ich habe einen Internetanschluss und mir wird vorgeworfen, dass über diesen Internetanschluss eine urheberrechtliche Verletzung gegangen wurde. Ich kann aber nachweisen, dass ich das selber nicht war. Dann geht es da um die Frage, bin ich Störer? Das heißt, habe ich mich beteiligt oder auch passiv an dieser Urheberrechtsverletzung? Ja oder nein?
Also bin ich verantwortlich zu machen, nur aufgrund der Tatsache, dass ich anderen Leuten Internet zur Verfügung stelle?
Korrekt.
Und jetzt, weil ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, habt ihr da irgendwie Zeug gemacht?
Es war mal eine Weile die Entwicklung in der Rechtsprechung. Man ist nicht mehr Störer, wenn man aufklärt, seine anderen Mitnutzer des Internets. Aufklärt darüber, dass Rechtsverletzungen, wie auch immer geartet, durch diesen Internetanschluss nicht begangen werden. Das ist Nummer eins.
Also eine Möglichkeit war zum Beispiel, sogenannte Splash-Pages vorzuschalten, die dich also, das ist in einigen Communities auch so geschehen, du wählst einen Freifunk-WLAN-Hotspot an und bekommst dann erst mal so eine Infoseite. Als allererstes, wo steht, hallo du, schön, hier, das ist Freifunk und so, und irgendwie Fair Use und außerdem möchte ich mich darüber aufklären, dass du keine legalen Sachen machen sollst.
Okay, und dann sagen, dann war ich juristisch raus?
Das war die Hoffnung.
Moment, Moment, das ist einmal diese Informationspflicht, Aufklärungspflicht und die zweite ist eine Prüfpflicht. Das heißt, ich muss auch tatsächlich überprüfen, ob derjenige sich an meine Aufklärung hält.
Das heißt, ich muss sie überwachen?
Also das gibt Urteile, die sind schon wieder ein paar Jahre alt, die diese Pflichten erarbeitet haben. Es gibt kein Gerichtlichsverfahren gegen einen Freifunker. Das heißt, das, was gab bis vor dem 7.7. nicht, dazu kommen wir gleich mit, davor gab es kein Verfahren gegen einen Freifunker. Es gab Abmahnung, sehr viel Abmahnung, aber kein Gerichtlichsverfahren. Das heißt, was ich hier erzähle...
Weil die Abmahnungen immer bezahlt wurden?
Nee, weder noch gar nichts. Wir haben keine Unterlassungserklärung abgegeben und auch kein Cent an die Abmahner überwiesen, sondern einfach nur geschrieben, dass es sich um Freifunk handelt, was Freifunk ist, dass das Internet keine Gefahrenzone ist, dass derjenige nicht Täter war und das halt begründet. Und dann gab es immer mal wieder noch Briefwechsel, teilweise Telefonate, wo mir mitgeteilt wurde, dass Freifunk illegal ist. Also es würde mal gerne dieses BGH-Urteil Sommer unseres Lebens von 2010 herangezogen. Also von Abmahnanwälten, wo sie dann halt gerne behaupten, dass in diesem BGH-Urteil generell die Information gab, rechtlich, dass das Teilen von einem Internetanschluss illegal ist. Das ist aber juristisch nicht haltbar, diese Argumentation. Wir haben jetzt am 07.07. um das endlich mal zu klären und um aus dieser Bedrohung herauszukommen, eine Feststellungsklage bei Gericht eingereicht.
Möchtest du noch mal einen Punkt unterschreiten? Also das ist so, Freifunker sind schon abgemahnt worden in der Vergangenheit. Aber es ist sozusagen immer, ihr habt da sozusagen immer gegenjuristiert.
Gericht, ja, aber eben bislang einfach nur eine Antwort geschrieben, dass wir das alles nicht so sehen und nicht anerkennen und dann immer gewartet, ob jetzt was passiert. Und in halt über zehn Jahren ist halt nichts passiert.
Okay, so und jetzt habt ihr mal gedacht, jetzt wollen wir es aber wissen oder wie?
Jetzt haben wir uns gedacht, wir wollen das Ganze vom Tisch haben. Also wir möchten geklärt haben, dass Freifunk legal ist, dass ich auch in Deutschland wie in vielen anderen Ländern meinen Internetzugang teilen kann, ohne dass damit eine Haftungsgefahr einhergeht.
Also ich kann mein Internet, also ihr denkt, es sollte mal rechtlich festgeschrieben werden, ich darf mein Internet teilen und ich werde nicht dafür verantwortlich gemacht, was andere Leute treiben.
Und die Verfahren sind anhängig. Anhängig ist ein rechtlicher Begriff, das heißt, das förmliche Verfahren wurde eingeleitet und der Gerichtskostenvorschuss wurde auch geleistet und damit wurden die Klagen den Abmahnern, also den Verwertungsinhabern zugestellt und den Prozessvertretern. In einem Fall gab es außergerichtlich dann ziemlich schnell die Reaktion, dass die Ansprüche gegen einen Freifunker zurückgenommen wurden. Und dann sind sie auch am ihre Karteien durchgegangen und haben sämtliche Ansprüche, die sie demjenigen gegenüber, also dem Freifunker, der geklagt hat, ausgesprochen haben, die wurden alle zurückgenommen. Das bedeutet aber erstmal nichts für das förmliche Verfahren, weil es außergerichtlich war.
Das heißt, ihr habt versucht, das mal bis zum Ende durchzuprügeln?
Wir prügeln das bis zum Ende durch, beide Verfahren. Die sind nicht beendet, die sind im Stadium, die Sachen liegen bei Gericht. Und die Richter werden entscheiden, was für ein Verfahren sie jetzt einleiten. Also, ob sie den frühen ersten Termin machen. Das machen sie, wenn die Sache relativ einfach ist. Und sie das dann schnell vom Tisch weg kriegen. Das wird in dem Fall nicht sein, weil du dich erinnerst, in der ersten halben Stunde habe ich ein paar Punkte aufgemacht, die ich natürlich auch in den Klageschriften aufgemacht habe. Das heißt, sie werden das schriftliche Vorverfahren anordnen. Und irgendwann im Herbst frühestens wird es da die möglichen Verhandlungen geben. Wir sind auch vor zwei Amtsgerichten in Berlin.
Aber dann muss ich jetzt auch mal fragen, es gab ja schon so eine kleine Welle, als da irgendwie diese anderen, also die Gegenpartei sozusagen, dieses zurückgezogen hat. Warum seid ihr dann darauf stolz, also wenn das Verfahren ja eigentlich noch total unentschieden ist?
Weil das so eine Richtungsweisung ist. Vielleicht haben sie gehofft, dass wir jetzt die Klage zurücknehmen, was wir natürlich nicht machen, weil wir dann die Kosten tragen würden. Weiß ich nicht, also ich bin wahrscheinlich nicht die Einzige, die Abmahn-Anwälte jetzt nicht für so sehr gute Juristen hält. Also das sind ja alles Standard-Schreiben, die da rausgehauen wären. Vielleicht haben sie da irgendwas erhofft in der Richtung, dass das Verfahren eben dann unter den Tisch fällt oder sowas aber eben nicht ist.
Also eben das quasi als Signal, dass es möglicherweise ganz gut aussieht.
Also als Signal, dass sie sich auf einen Rechtsstreit nicht einlassen. Aber das ist nur einer der beiden Fälle. In dem anderen Fall ist nichts passiert, ist nichts außerrichtlich passiert.
Also dass sie das zurückgezogen haben, das heißt, dann wird der eine jetzt beendet oder ihr macht ihn trotzdem weiter?
Alle beide werden weiter gemacht.
Also die Abmahnindustrie bewegt sich ja auch auf sehr dünnem Eis und das weiß sie selber. Und wenn es halt zu einem Gerichtsverfahren kommen würde, dann könnte halt ihr gesamtes Geschäftsmodell zusammenbrechen.
Okay, jetzt habt ihr gleich zwei am Start. Na da bin ich ja gespannt. Wie sind denn, also ich meine, klar, ihr seht es wahrscheinlich positiv sozusagen die Erfolgsaufsichten, aber wie sicher seid ihr da?
Es gibt so ein paar Urteile, die denke ich schon in eine ganz gute Richtung weisen in der letzten Zeit. Da gab es drei, vier. Das eine war, dass Kaffeebetreiber sozusagen plötzlich nicht mehr in der Störerhaftung waren, dass Ferienwohnungsbetreiber, Hotelbetreiber nicht mehr in der Störerhaftung sind. Das zeigt alles in so eine Richtung. Dann war ein Vater, das war das Biershare, ein Vater nicht für seinen volljährigen Sohn verantwortlich. Da wurde auch das Thema dieser Aufklärungspflichten diskutiert. Dann gab es noch einen anderen Fall, wo es auch einmal ein minderjähriges Kind ging. Also wie viel man muss überhaupt aufklären? Also Erwachsene muss definitiv nicht aufklären. Dann kann ich davon ausgehen, dass die wissen, was Recht und Unrecht ist und so weiter. Und so zeigt eigentlich vieles immer mehr in diese Richtung, dass das eigentlich nicht zu halten ist. Also es gibt immer mehr Urteile, wobei die Fälle ja immer so ein bisschen anders gelagert sind. Und unsere Idee ist jetzt hier, dass für offensichtlich offene, also weil wenn das Freifunk heißt, dann man mal nachguckt, was Freifunk ist, dann ist das halt sehr schnell klar, was hier die Intention ist und dass das öffentlich zugänglich ist und von mehreren genutzt wird, hierfür mal klarzustellen, wobei am liebsten noch einen Schritt weiter. Wir sind ja auch Privatleute.
Also in dem Fall, wenn diese beiden Urteile sozusagen für euch positiv ausgehen, dann würde das erst mal bedeuten, dass es zwei Urteile gibt, die für Freifunker das relativ fest treiben, wo sie dann auch wieder andere Gerichte orientieren. Also es ist dann noch nicht irgendwie Gesetz, aber wäre dann, sagen Sie Wegweisungen. Aber dass das für alle gilt, also ich als Privatperson gebe einfach mal ein Internet frei, das wäre dann noch mal ein Schritt.
Na, das sind ja Privatpersonen. Wir sind ja also die Freifunker, also, ne?
Aber trotzdem, Gerichtsurteile sind immer bedingt übertragbar. Das heißt, wir wissen nicht, was jetzt herauskommt. Das gilt nach wie vor auf hoher See und vor Gericht ist man in Gottes Hand, also.
Wir reden jetzt jetzt zwei Stunden und im Prinzip steht nichts fest.
Ja, aber es werden ja auch viele Fragen aufgeworfen. Zum Beispiel kann man sich fragen, warum die großen Provider eigentlich nicht unter die Störerhaftung fallen. Weil eigentlich sind es ja auch nur, also der normale Mensch, der seinen Freifunk-Router oder anderen Leuten zur Verfügung stellt, den Internetzugang darüber, den unterscheide ich eigentlich auch nichts von dem großen Provider, außer die Größe. Wo zieht man da die Grenze?
Entschuldigung, ich weiß, das wird nicht funktionieren, aber ich möchte jetzt kurz mit gesundem Menschenverstand argumentieren. Also wenn ich als Privatperson meinen Internetanschluss einer Handvoll Leute zur Verfügung stelle und damit nicht mal was verdiene, dann bin ich also möglicherweise Störer. Wenn jetzt eine riesige Firma 100.000 Leute Internet gibt und damit auch noch Geld verdient, also die macht ja quasi, also jetzt mal aus Verwertungsrechte Perspektive, die macht ja quasi Geld damit, dass Leute illegal Zeug runterladen können. Wieso sind die denn keine Störer?
Haftungsprivileg Paragraph 8 Telemedien Gesetz.
Was heißt das?
Dass Provider haftungsprivilegiert sind, Übersetzung, Haftungsprivilegierung. Sie haben eine bestimmte Position in der Gesellschaft inne durch ihre Tätigkeit, ihre wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit sind sie geschützt davor, dass Schadensersatzansprüche gegen sie geltend gemacht werden. Aber jetzt kommen wir gleich zu dem nächsten Punkt. Die Frage ist, wann ist man Provider? Das ist eine große Thematik bei uns. Wann ist ein Freifunk Provider? Also schließlich vermittelt er ja auch den Zugang zum Internet. Und bei § 8 Telemediengesetz ist auch die Frage, bezieht sich das nur auf Schadensersatzansprüche oder auch auf Unterlassungsansprüche? Unterlassungsansprüche, dahinter hinter diesem Begriff finden wir die Störerhaftung. Ich gehöre zu denjenigen, die behaupten, § 8 Telemediengesetz ist so weit formuliert, dass sowohl Schadensersatz- wie auch Unterlassungsansprüche darunter fallen. Das heißt, die Privilegierung komplett für den Provider ist. Da gibt es keine Abmahn-Möglichkeit. Die Abmahn-Industrien gehen aber natürlich nicht gegen Telekom oder O2 oder et cetera, habe Deutschland vor, weil die haben natürlich erstens eine riesengroße Rechtsabteilung und sie können sich Wirtschaftskanzleien leisten. Das heißt, dort hätten schon viel früher negative Feststellungsklagen eingereicht.
Okay, da haben sie sich also nicht getraut. Immer auf die Kleinen. Jetzt könnte man sich vorstellen, es gibt verschiedene Wege, die ihr da gerade einschlagt, die dann möglicherweise diese Störerhaftung rauskippen oder abschaffen, wenn man so will. Könnte man ja auf die Idee kommen, dass dann die Leute, die so mit der Verwertungsrechten Geld verdienen, sagen, na ja, dann lass uns doch mal schnell ein neues Gesetz lobbyieren, dass das wieder alles anders wird. Wie sieht es denn politisch aus in dieser Richtung?
Also momentan ist ja die digitale Agenda im Gespräch, die uns die GroKo hier versprochen hat, also sprich eine Reform vom Internetrecht an den verschiedensten Stellen. Unter anderem auch das Thema Störerhaftung soll hier angegangen werden. Auf netzpolitik.org konnte man kürzlich einen Leak, also eine Vorveröffentlichung eines Entwurfs sozusagen begutachten, der uns so gar nicht gefallen hat und den wir momentan für eine komplette Luftnummer halten. Weil dort das ganze Thema nur für Gewerbetreibende, sprich diese Urteil, die wir schon haben, WLAN-Cafés, Hotels und so weiter, die sollen da sozusagen auch mit diesem Haftungsprivileg und so weiter da ausgestattet werden, die sollen quasi als Provider gelten. Vom Privatpersonen oder freien Community-Netzwerken oder sowas steht da halt leider nichts. Und wir haben auch noch eine viel schlimmere Befürchtung, nämlich dass es jetzt so Richtung Registrierungszwang dann noch geht. Da stehen auch so Ideen drin, wie man muss dann da seine Handynummer abliefern.
Wie als Netzbetreiber? Also ich logge mich bei Freifunk ein und dann müsste dann quasi so ein Formular kommen, hier gib deine Wassromme ein.
Bei uns wird das garantiert nicht kommen.
Was meinen die mit dem Vorschlag?
Also der Vorschlag sagt dann sozusagen, ja, du kannst also du könntest dann hier als Provider vielleicht also erstmal nur für Gewerbetreibende, wie gesagt. Und die Befürchtung ist dann halt, dass man sich dann noch registrieren muss. Also was man mit seiner Handynummer sozusagen, dass man sagen muss, ich nutze jetzt hier dieses Netz von dem Kaffeebetreiber.
Und dann müsste der sozusagen den Datenverkehr überwachen oder wie?
Na der kann das ja dann zuordnen sozusagen. Ja, nur wenn das überwacht. Na ja, erstmal weiß er überhaupt wer, also man schränkt da den Personenkreis schon erheblich ein, wenn man weiß, welche Telefonnummern oder welche Menschen mit welcher Telefonnummern da sozusagen als Täter in Frage kommen bei möglichen illegalen Aktionen.
Okay, also das ist sozusagen dieses Haftungsprivileg für kleine Leute, sage ich jetzt mal, steht also in dem neuen Entwurf nicht drin, aber die Entscheidung, die über diese Urteile gefällt werden, ist quasi zweigleisig, was da gerade gefahren wird. Einmal Haftungsprivileg ausweiten und das andererseits Störerhaftung generell abschaffen oder wie sehe ich das?
In der negativen Feststellungsklage habe ich das aufgenommen mit 8TMG, dass die Freifunker auch Provider sind und unter die Privilegierung von 8TMG ist. Also wir haben in den beiden Klagen die Sachen thematisiert und die Gerichte müssten darüber urteilen.
Aber du hast vielleicht recht. Das eine ist ja, dass die Juristen oder die Gerichte eine Realität schaffen, durch ihre Urteile und eigentlich richtiger wäre es, eben auch politisch ganz klar die Richtung anzusagen und die ist eben nicht klar genug angesagt. Das ist eben noch nicht der eindeutige politische Wille, allen Menschen Internetzugang zu ermöglichen und dafür alle Möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen. So und da geht es genau darum, diese neue digitale Agenda oder diesen Punkt, der auch Reformierung der Störerhaftung da zu beeinflussen politisch. Und da gab es auch mal von der digitalen Gesellschaft ein Gesetzesentwurf, schon etwas länger her, aber das ist im Prinzip immer noch in diesem Zusammenhang aktuell, wo die mal einen Vorschlag gemacht haben, wie denn so ein Störerhaftungsthema zukünftig aussehen sollte.
Wir saßen da auch in Sitzungen in der Politik und haben leider mal wieder feststellen müssen, dass doch der große Teil dort eher die Internetausdrucker sind, die so etwas zu entscheiden haben.
Das Internet ist voller alter Menschen.
Ich will das noch mal wiederholen, wir brauchen diese neue Gesetzgebung nicht. Nach meiner Meinung und anderen Juristen sind auch der Meinung, ich fürchte das wie Monique, dass es eine Angstgesetzgebung geben wird. Das heißt, für Gewerbetreibende, auch Kleingewerbetreibende, wird es vielleicht auch die Privilegierung geben mit Voraussetzungen, dass da eben protokolliert wird, dass man eventuell irgendwelche Verletzungen dann verfolgen kann. Lieber den Achtthemen gehen, so lassen, wie er ist, aber in der Rechtsprechung weiter auslegen. Und zwar bezieht sich die Privilegierung auf Schadensersatz und Unterlassen. Das heißt, jeder Provider ist privilegiert von der Störerhaftung. Er unterliegt nicht der Störerhaftung und Freifunker. Also jeder der anderen einen Internetzugang ermöglicht, ist Provider.
Es wird aber nicht nur Freifunker, sondern auch Hotels, Cafébetreiber, du, deine Oma, jeder, WGs.
Also faktisch wäre dann die Störerhaftung abgeschafft.
Richtig.
Für das offene WLAN.
Genau, wir haben den 8 TMG, der ist wunderbar offen formuliert. Man muss ihn so anwenden, wie er formuliert ist. Und es gibt viele Juristen, die genau die gleiche Rechtsmeinung haben. Man muss es nur vor Gericht durchboxen.
Puh, Gesetzen fallen jetzt irgendwie, dass diese Urteile gehen so aus, wie ihr wollt. Aber die Gesetzesänderung, also diese digitale Agenda, sagt das genaue Gegenteil. Was sticht dann?
Das Gesetz sticht.
Also das, was dann neu kommt quasi. Dann müsste man das alles noch mal von vorne anfangen.
Na dann, naja, die neuere Gesetze sind immer sehr eng, konkret formuliert. Da wird wahrscheinlich nicht viel Raum sein, tatsächlich vor Gericht zu gehen. Gibt es so eine neue Tendenz?
Gibt es schon einen Plan B, wenn das jetzt sozusagen mit der Störerhaftung irgendwie noch ganz schlimm werden sollte für Freifunk?
Andere Parteien wählen?
Zum Beispiel. Der Plan B ist ja sozusagen 99, 9 Prozent der Fälle schon am Start. Das ist ja eine deutsche Rechtsprecher. Um mit VPN-Tunneln ins Ausland zu anderen Providern in europäische Nachbarländer, wo dieser Quatsch halt nicht am Start ist, ist die eine Möglichkeit und die andere Möglichkeit ist eben, der Förderverein Freien Netzwerke, wie gesagt, ist providerregistriert bei der Bundesnetzagentur und insofern auch privilegiert.
Also das heißt sozusagen, man kann über Freifunk teilnehmen, über diesen Verein?
Ja, kann man, genau. Man kann auch routen zu uns, machen auch deutschlandweit einige Communities. Also nicht nur die Berliner Community, weil der Verein ist in Berlin ansässig, tun das, nutzen diese Möglichkeit. Die weiteren Freifunk-Vereine könnten hier nachziehen, können nebenfalls Provider werden. Wir könnten andere unabhängige Provider unseres Vertrauens hinzuziehen. Das müssen auch nicht alle Vereine jetzt zwingen, Provider werden. Da gibt es dann so ein paar andere Risiken, Stolpersteine, die man dann da beachten muss. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich auf die jetzt noch eingehen soll, aber auf jeden Fall ja. Also da gibt es schon Lösungen.
Das ist unheimliche Bürokratie bei der Bundesnetzagentur, dieses Privileg zu bekommen. Das ist ein einfaches Schreiben, das kann man einfach abschicken.
Aber eigentlich wollen wir überhaupt keine Bürokratie, einfach wollen wir nur unser Netz aufbauen und das mit anderen teilen können.
Alles klar, das war's im Chaosradio 203 über Freifunk und Störerhaftung und diesen ganzen juristischen Kram fürchterlich. Bea, Monique und Mirko, vielen Dank. Gibt es noch irgendwas, was man in meinem letzten Satz zusammenfassen kann? Außer wir wollen freie Netze?
Ja, Freiheit ist super toll.
Freifunk Statt Angst.
Ihr könnt diese Sendung als Podcast hören, wird im Laufe der Nacht erscheinen, auf fritz.de, später dann auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Ich danke allen Gästen, ihr könnt gerne im nächsten Monat zuhören, da findet das Chaos Radio nur im Chaos Computer Club statt, hier auf fritz.de und in zwei Monaten dann hier wieder auf fritz.de. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine Nachricht für euch, lasst sie nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.